[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bonjour tout le monde salut à tous et
bienvenue pour ce match de championnat
du monde salut le Fab salut keV salut à
tous donc attendez une petite seconde on
se règle bien les derniers réglages
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire en amont en
Benoît bien évidemment et comme tu vois
je suis un peu en train de regarder déjà
la cam de déjà la nôtre mais aussi celle
du match qui sont pas réglées
alors attends mon Fab je suis en petite
réflexion on verra après au niveau de
micro 600 bon mais je suis en premier
lieu en train tu vois parce que les
camel
alors je sais pas pourquoi on a fait des
tests hier ça marchait ça marchait pas
et là j'ai l'impression que alors
alors on a ça
[Musique]
c'est
au moins un être surveillance
alors attends on va vérifier que ça
marche bien ton micro et je pense que tu
vas passer au micro casque mon Fab ah
merde je parle trop mal dedans
tu manques de puissance parlante quoi
t'es pas bien quand même non bah non
j'ai pas bien parce que j'ai pas
l'habitude de parler là-dedans
intensif donc attends le cas c'est le
casque il est là est-ce que tu peux
vérifier qu'il soit bien branché de
l'autre côté aussi et on va on va
l'allumer on va le mettre en il l'est et
ça va être le numéro 2 donc E4 5
OK et bien et là tout d'un coup
ok je vais faire semblant de parler dans
le micro là et
un double micro bon qu'est-ce que ça va
être une sorte de marshallah encore anti
Marchal
[Musique]
vraiment la taille de digue elle veut
but en fait je crois qu'ils sont en
train de la régler ouais les flous
en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai lu sur sur
Twitter le pronostic c'était Marshall
sur Twitter
c'est bon
bon on va voir s'il a si la renforcé du
match contre Magnus
sachant que c'est pas Magnus en face
peut-être que ce soit pas mal nu sur la
grosse diff
usion
[Rires]
on est parti on va voir cette première
partie généralement première partie de
championnat du monde il y a beaucoup de
match nul dans les premières game
en match
[Musique]
il faut essayer de pas perdre c'est
possible la première
peut-être qui marchait le micro d'avant
désolé hein c'était peut-être le mauvais
en fait il faut vraiment que tu regardes
lequel va dans quoi fabab
désolé les amis
le casque
ça les femmes je crois qu'on s'est
trompé je crois qu'on a fait
on attend pour le moment l'ouverture
ouais difficulté c'est qu'on a beaucoup
de délai avec le chat aussi donc on peut
on peut un peu suer pourquoi
parce que on est sur twitch et sur
Youtube donc ah oui toujours
[Musique]
ça ça nous fait
ce petit ce petit délai après ils nous
ont fait une belle cadence
est magnifique
c'est une cadence de type longue on l'a
on la voit dans le chat
il change de ligne il fait un petit truc
j'avance
non l'idée
c'est que dans les Espagnols d'échange
classique
ouais après petit rock les Noirs ils
aiment bien pouvoir faire F6 ils ont pas
le cavalier qui est sur la case et le
foot case noir aussi il va pas enlever
cette il va aller en C5 on décide ou je
sais pas quoi et donc et donc en fait ce
petit recul pour reprendre
bah c'est intéressant c'est une petite
ligne et donc voilà c'est la tentative
qui fait ici donc c'est une sorte
d'antimarchal mais très tôt
c'est peut-être le genre de choses qu'on
aurait aimé le voir faire contre Carlson
d'ailleurs en réalité puisque il s'était
un peu enféré dans dans les ouvertures
de Magnus dans le dans l'anti Marshall
de manus on aurait aimé le voir tester
autre chose et je suis étonné qui teste
d'entrée contreding comme ça
ouais alors après donc oui c'est pas
censé être trop risqué pour les blancs
comme ligne
[Musique]
c'est soit tu joues avec D4 et tu sais
d'échanger et avoir ta majorité à
l'endroit etc soit tu fais plus des
trois
jeux plus fermé et tu mets un peu les
cavaliers ça peut être qu'il y ait des
deux qui est C4 ou d'aller vers G3
toujours de l'autre côté et de venir
vers la case F5 et c'est assez solide
c'est pas mal en fait et c'est une
structure qu'on a l'habitude de voir on
va dire parfois dans les antibérinoises
quand ils font des trois un peu tôt et
qu'ils échangent dans ces 6 plus tard
comme ça donc ouais c'est une structure
qui arrive mais qui
ouais assez solide et pourquoi pas c'est
un choix a-t-on d'autres Cannes on va
aller jeter un œil femme
alors ça c'est pareil
c'est la même mais on a dodo un peu
mieux on a ça en plus alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'il est assis sur
on n'a pas l'air d'être bien
on est d'accord les gars on a besoin du
chat là
il y avait un problème évidemment Fab
[Musique]
ah non mais je me disais aussi on le
voyait pas à gauche on le voyait à
droite
on va rester comme ça pour le moment
avec le playerview avec les règles quand
même une histoire saine machin tu as 2
millions d'euros de prix quand même
c'est important par l'argent le
vainqueur se qualifie pour le
championnat du monde 2024
est déjà parti et Ding qui réfléchit bah
écoute on va direct un coup moral pour
le Concorde marche
et je vois qu'on n'a pas les ponts alors
attends il y a un petit problème aussi
sur les pendules petit problème
d'affichage qui va être réglé
immédiatement enfin
pas faire nul par consentement mutuel
c'est ça avant
le 4e rapide
non pas de petite nulle et ouais donc
comme vous le voyez là on vient
d'allumer les pendules il y a encore
quand même le temps pour les joueurs
puisque même s'il est un petit peu en
difficulté dans ce début de partie
surpris par la préparation adverse ingli
Rennes il a quand même encore 1h54 là
pour pour répondre donc il a quand même
le temps
de trouver un coup qui qui lui plaît
ouais bon il peut faire quoi
qui a aidé ça peut-être j'ai quatre
peut-être
sûrement un des deux coups non
la théorie et cette fougères il y a très
peu de parties non mais c'est toi qui
est un peu rare je crois c'est des trois
plutôt
on va regarder
c'est des trois ou un ouais demain j'ai
déjà vu mais c'est pas terrible
c'est logique après au-delà de ça bah
disons ouais tu te gardes la souplesse
de dégâts c'est-à-dire s'en fout des 6
j'imagine tu prends des cadres dans la
tronche direct
c'est marrant parce que tu aurais perdu
un temps et lui aussi a perdu un temps
mais tu aurais pas jouer ouais dans les
espaces
à plat qui est pas terrible
alors menace
[Musique]
ça dépend juste le pion tu t'annonces
qu'il est préparé sur les deux
probablement
pas je pense
ouais en tout cas il a pas révisé ça
priori c'est inattendu comme choix
après normalement ils ont tout vu quand
même dans leur vie
ouais mais entre vois et connaître il y
a quand même il y a quand même un
monde
il y a quand même un petit monde
enfin je pense
[Musique]
je suis quand même pas en faire mon
répertoire principal tout le temps quoi
ouais mais ça peut être une petite idée
une petite variante pour un joueur
d'espagnol affûté comme toi
ça peut ça peut surprendre parfois on
nous propose Dame des 6 je pense que
c'est des problèmes non
mais je sais pas voilà l'idée de Fab le
coup de femme qui a validé à trois pour
venir toucher la case C4 ça c'est le
coup de fable le coup de Kev D4 pour
faire un piégeot puis on prend et au
sein
non mais je pense que les deux coups
sont jouables déjà
[Musique]
du coup c'est quoi ce qui est 17 ou
chemins
et tu as toutes les pièces bien
donc ce sera fougé 4 ou cavaliers
ou je sais pas quoi mais
j'aime pas cet avant-décis comme toi
mais ouais j'arrive pas à réfuter non
plus non mais même dans la vraie
quoi ouais non mais je l'ai vu j'ai
juste bouger donc je me suis posé la
question
alors je sais pas pourquoi cette caméra
est comme ça j'en ai aucune idée alors
si les gens disent ils ont une meilleure
des meilleures caméras en anglais le
truc c'est aussi qu'ils ont énormément
plus de moyens de régie nous on n'a pas
pu mettre absolument toutes les caméras
qui existent et on peut pas
tout changer
en réalité on en a pas mal des cames
mais
[Musique]
celles pour avoir le set up avec Ding et
Machin on a surtout celle-là et ah
peut-être par contre la caméra du haut
là elle est peut-être maintenant temps
pas autant de temps que ça joue
ah non la pendule
oui non c'est pas possible non
il peut pas avoir dépenser 5 minutes
en tout cas ouais on va dire Ding il est
hors prépa
qui va pas te faire du Parker il connaît
le genre de position ça c'est sûr par
contre il a déjà dû voir dans loin d'un
souvenir mais là du coup il est un peu
tout seul
sur les cités
on va attendre qu'il joue son coup de
toute façon on a bien vu les options
on a bien vu les options qu'il avait
maintenant c'est à lui de faire le choix
maintenant ça lui de faire le choix
d'après du coup sur qu'il y a des
dessins qui je sais pas de base c'est un
coup que j'aurais plus ou moins
spontanément mais je sais pas si il est
bon c'est le pire des trois mais est-ce
que est-ce qu'on veut faire des quatre
est-ce que on veut faire ces trois D4 ou
c'est quoi son idée heureux en fait
c'est le fait de pas faire des trois
c'est sûrement que tu veux dire
on va le savoir puisqu'il vient de le
jouer donc simplement attendre la
réponse à ta question à Fab non mais tu
vois pour moi c'est le coup le plus
naturel mais bon ok je suis pas un
expert des gens de position mais
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire des quatre
maintenant si c'est le garde en réserve
il développe il fait ces trois est-ce
que est-ce que c'est B3 B3 fou B2 D4
on va voir on va en train de regarder là
[Musique]
c'est pas de bol j'aurais bien on n'a
pas enfin on a pu on a arrêté sur le
geste là
c'est pas relevé tempo bizarrement
bizarre
autant de café un niveau intestinal il
était souvent debout
donc il a joué des quatre et il attend
tranquille
allez tu vois le temps maintenant ça y
est il est bon à une 47 pour Ding c'est
voilà c'est la réalité là qui est
revenue
je peux pas grand chose de partir à ce
niveau durant environ combien de temps
généralement entre 3h30 et 7h quelque
chose comme ça
tu peux te mettre 4 ans de moyenne
donc déjà oui
donc il va prendre un
puis on prend je dirais d'en prendre il
revient en tout cas ça y est il est
assis
[Musique]
oui ça paraît logique de hockey ici
le pion G7 est attaqué un tout bêtement
il faut le défendre bah tu décales le
roi tu peux penser
donc
là c'est c'est pas le moment de faire un
FIFA
un tout petit peu plus y penser ça
propose
d'échangerai pas non c'est non je veux
faire c'est horrible rock et puis voilà
quoi on en parle plus
ok bon alors on est posé quoi le
placement des pièces il va jouer vite de
toute façon c'est sûr
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as un monde où tu as
réussi à faire ça
peut-être mais bon pas évident non bon
tout de suite à nos questions à chaque
fois donc ok faut fit 4 bon ça regarde
la colonne des mais est-ce que c'est si
grave après c'est une autre histoire
mais tu as pas très envie de te dire
merde mais comment je lutte c'est cette
colonne
va vite hein
je voulais dire un coup bête mais il est
pas
conçu
français 7 merci au revoir mais en fait
c'est de me prendre 8 à
faire des trucs
[Musique]
non mais en fait ok bon il va pas
répéter l'idée mais sur une partie je
sais pas
non c'est sûr que ça si tu fais tourner
l'ordi tu t'es égalises en force sans
aucun problème ça j'en suis convaincu
c'est ça
qui a beaucoup de parties d'ordi et que
j'ai 5 G4 mais bon franchement si il
fait G5 digne
ouais mais il a pas l'air mais si il
fait sans connaître voilà non mais là il
connaît
un petit contrôle un moment donné voilà
voilà bon on va faire deux trois petites
fouilles pendant la partie peut-être
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il se lève
d'ailleurs
pour les fouilles
pendant les parties
non mais ok j'ai
je peux pas
imaginer le coup
bien sûr
[Musique]
je pense pas qu'ils connaissent ou alors
peut-être qu'il connaît et puis qu'il
essaye un peu de se rappeler parce qu'il
dit ouais comme je faisais pion devant
moi faut vraiment être bien sûr mais si
tu connais pas tu fais pas c'est
impossible mais j'aurais même pas pensé
j'aurais pas songer j'ai 5 comme coup
possible quoi et je vois quelqu'un je
veux ça je dis ok c'est quoi cet abruti
quoi enfin
où tu vérifies
bah sur le coup je vérifie pas une fois
que j'ai perdu la partie quand même il y
a une bizarre rire
il y a certains joueurs à mon avis qui
te l'envoie le gsimko
alors est-ce que si ça vibre mais que tu
es pas sûr que ce soit méchant G5 il
joue quand même ou pas imaginons ça
vibre
non mais non tu joues bon tu sens tu
tends ton code Morse qui vibre dans le
Fiona 5
en sachant tu vois que tu auras pas de
vibration à tous les coups genre
je fais pas tu fais pas
de l'ordi il a fait quoi
le coup de keV
deux informations il est pas préparé il
a pas de Plug et je pense pas que les
pots changera évidemment
[Musique]
le plan sur le nez
j'adore les fonds avec la tête des
joueurs c'est
pas c'est oppressant non c'est ce qu'ils
disent qu'il se lève beaucoup et que ils
veulent
je pense qu'il connaît pendant encore
longtemps
donc après il peut peut-être croire que
l'autre va connaître G5 tu peux pas sûr
qu'ils connaissent pas mais
en tout cas ça
alors tu me demandes mon avis tu me dis
tiens à ton avis là-dessus qu'est-ce
qu'on va jouer pour l'instant je leur
dis qu'il est 7 j'aurais dit ouais c'est
que des coups genre logique
complètement
en tout cas le dame 3 est joué donc ici
ça semble normal
[Musique]
bon écoute on va avoir comment ça
continue cavaler aussi ça semble être le
coup peut-être
[Musique]
si je pouvais pour essayer de du petit
ordi en tout cas dame 2
[Musique]
c'est peut-être là tu as un coup
difficile avec les Noirs à ce moment là
mais est-ce que ouais est-ce que tu es
dégâts c'est si impossible
[Musique]
c'est une bonne ouverture pour une
époque parce que c'est une partie graine
une partie gratuite avec les Blancs soit
nul soit gain alors vous allez voir
pendant le Championnat du Monde
énormément en partie dans ce oui dans ce
registre où les Blancs ne pourront pas
perdre ni à part gaffe et metron petite
pression sur les Noirs c'est juste à ce
niveau de préparation et de la
compétition c'est juste normal les
quasiment toutes les parties sont à deux
résultats
oui si souvent en fait mais derrière
souvent dans les premières
sinepo bon bah là en fait c'est lui qui
a surpris mais si Ding est avec la bonne
prépa ou quoi je pense qu'il va pas
insister à prendre le risque c'est dans
ce cas-là en fait si les noirs sont
super bien préparés les blancs sont
hyper ils veulent pas perdre
mais
[Musique]
genre je me souviens crâne par exemple
il s'attendait pas à la slave quoi la
première il doit faire ses prendre quoi
pour dire ok je joue pas après bon il
révise la troisième il refait bon les
prises avec les Blancs parce que mais
bon ça c'est une autre histoire mais la
première en tout cas tu veux même pas
tester
[Musique]
je m'attendais pas je veux pas prendre
le risque
intéressant on a de nouveau une scène
qu'on a beaucoup eu pendant les derniers
matchs champions du monde et aussi
pendant les candidats c'est ça fait déjà
plus de 5 minutes Fabien qu'on a aucun
joueur assis c'est la première fois de
depuis le début de championnat du monde
mais ça arrivait après 20 minutes de jeu
donc premier et premier moment déjà 4
minutes sans personne à la table de jeu
est-ce qu'il faut raccourcir les
cadences ou pas je ne pense pas il faut
rapprocher des chiottes peut-être
depuis les chiottes en fait l'avenir des
échecs sur Internet c'est tout le monde
en réel mais
vu depuis les chiens bah tiens pour la
prochaine backup on va pas jouer sur les
ordis on jouera depuis des chiottes de
l'espace en fait mais ce qu'ils sont au
courant ce qui nous ont préparé un petit
échecs plaisir ouais
alors et oui si ça joue aussi tôt c'est
tout simplement à cause du décalage
horaire puisque ils sont Kazakhstan
ouais ouais ils sont Kazakhstan donc qui
organise beaucoup de choses là ils ont
fait le glitter rapide
en décembre et là ils font ça
ils sont ils sont très chauds sur les
échecs en ce moment
et c'est tant mieux
a priori Ding réfléchit depuis les
chiottes
il regarde la télé
en fait il faudrait une régie
professionnelle et c'était pas possible
pour nous de
d'avoir une régie professionnelle
et non je l'ai pas celle-là
en tout cas elle répond pas elle répond
pas
mais bon c'est quand même
c'est suffisant ce qu'on a là pour
poursuivre le match
là mais bon c'est des budgets régies bon
en fait un chèque de 100000 balles et
puis on aura peut-être la ressemblent
quoi mais non mais c'est énorme en fait
après ça demande vraiment d'avoir une
régie des techniciens pendant trois
semaines enfin c'est un mec qui clique
sur la caméra à chaque fois avec les
serveurs qui tiennent et surtout les
ordinateurs
mais bon le problème c'est que il
faudrait que ça touche l'essence 150 000
viewers par stream tu vois là on est
1400 bons
le soir quoi et je peux te dire que je
connais pas 100000 € par mois
donc
c'est pas c'est pas évident on peut pas
tout avoir c'est on aurait trop de trop
de bugs
puis bon normalement quand tu regardes
une compétition sportive mais les mecs
ils sont sur le terrain ils sont pas au
vestiaire la coupe du monde de foot tu
es pas en train d'avoir en plein match
la caméra du vestiaire enfin c'est
comme ça
bon du coup
je suis pas sûr c'est une bonne image
des échecs d'avoir les joueurs qui
réfléchissent depuis la salle de repos
enfin moi c'est on a déjà parlé au
dernier championnat du monde de candidat
je
peux pas ça normal mais bon après non
mais surtout enfin
bon on va dire ok moi je suis pour les
échecs en réel en fait plus que tous les
temps sur internet
et du coup si c'est pour faire ça
non quoi ok je veux que que les mecs
soient assis qui appuies sur la chic et
en 3D et que et que c'est une présence
physique et qui est quelque chose
après bon que tu joues ton coup tu te
balades ça c'est j'ai pas l'interdire
enfin je fais moi-même quand je joue et
je gère tout le monde
obligé de réfléchir depuis depuis la
chaise de jeu je trouve enfin moi je
veux dire ok tu as le droit d'aller aux
toilettes cette envie c'est pas le
problème mais quand tu finis tu reviens
quoi tu vas pas on reste où mais il
revient
après je comprends qu'il le fasse vu que
c'est autorisé c'est pas une nouvelle
fois absolument rien contre Ding mais je
trouve ça dommage de
voilà parce qu'en fait j'ai l'impression
d'insister une épreuve de conduite chef
vraiment en fait il a trouvé le coup
on s'entraîne aussi tellement avec les
ordinateurs c'est peut-être devenu plus
facile de réfléchir en 2D pour tout le
monde
[Musique]
pour une fois il joue pas de tempo tempo
donc c'est que c'est pas le coup main
des Noirs déjà
et
[Musique]
ok alors qu'est-ce qu'il veut si
bon est-ce que je sais pas on a
[Musique]
plusieurs coups bêtement pour se
développer
j'aurais mis le bain
on peut aussi bouger qu'il y a eu ça ou
je sais pas quoi moi
[Musique]
je sais pas je le sens bien des deux
quand c'est C3 mais bon après peut-être
je suis con mais sans ces trois je sais
pas ce que je vais en faire
[Musique]
et donc ouais vouloir le sortir en
disant au moins madame elle souffle j'ai
pas le fou bloqué bon c'est plus ou
moins logique de se poser la question
quoi
fougères donc si c'est pas qu'il y a eu
des deux locaux
ok 5 c'est le premier coup tu as envie
de regarder puisque tu dis attention le
fou j'imagine qu'il repars en H5 pour
contrôler D1 et pas se prendre une
vingtaine pour
peut-être dommage 3 ouais tu tapes ça
c'est vraiment logique
il faut G6 tu te barres et on a le temps
de le bouffer on le bouffera un jour
mais non
commentaire puis on prend et c'est pas
cavalier
aussi cette fois
c'est quand même un peu mieux avec les
Blancs moi je préfère mais bon l'ordi ça
vient de dames 5 c'est ça le problème
genre
des trucs bizarres mais oui il a raison
on suit un peu pour
B26 je retourne lui il est hyper mauvais
en C3
et ouais
c'est le coup numéro 1 de l'ordi mais
peut-être qu'il sait en fait
donc il veut aller
probablement vers F5
[Musique]
donc là clairement il sait
là clairement il sait
donc cavalier aussi
[Musique]
le truc c'est que tu veux pas tolérer le
camion aussi
mais là il sait parce que ça c'est
avantage blanc mais de base tu prendrais
pas le choix aussi vite de laisser la
paire de fou toi
[Musique]
bon et cette position là tu vas pédaler
pour comprendre que c'est pas mieux ou
tu vas te tromper tu vas te tromper
c'est juste pour dire que si il a joué
cavalier des quatre aussi vite c'est que
c'est qu'il savait
en tout cas d'être au courant que le
caillot aussi c'est la tour de contrôle
tu veux la dégommer
plus avantageux que l'autre franchement
intuitif parce que dans l'autre tu as
doublé les pions même c'est pas super
grave mais quand même c'est un petit
truc et tu as gagné la paire de fou il
faut que tu comprennes que il vaut mieux
laisser les deux fous à l'adversaire et
une structure depuis un peu plus propre
pour avoir l'avantage oui pour le jouer
aussi vite ce qu'il a des réfléchi 2
minutes ou 3 minutes c'est impossible tu
réfléchis pas 3 minutes pour une
décision aussi importante je pense oui
mais non mais même les pots
[Musique]
ok j'ai l'impression peut-être dans le
genre de position tu peux tu peux
travailler avec les Blancs et c'est toi
Maxime qui dit sans savoir tu joues pas
qu'il y a eu des cartes aussi vite
donc c'est il a toujours su
non c'est sûr c'est sûr qui c'est
magnifique pour pour Ding bon mais bien
préparé
non mais ça va mais
il donnait pas cette impression contre
Magnus quoi
mais surtout que là de toute façon
qu'elle lui aussi si tu vas probablement
le faire enfin je veux dire
c'est évident enfin c'est sûr mais du
coup il a vraiment un truc avec les
Blancs
prépa DIF
mais c'est dommage pour que côté une
époque il est pas un truc comme ça
tu peux rien faire de même si l'ordi te
donne 0,30 ou j'en sais rien quoi en
fait tu vas pas le réalisant en partie
quoi il ne refait pas les mêmes erreurs
comme est-ce que précédent il a quelque
part tiré des leçons
oui l'expérience elle doit servir c'est
d'ailleurs c'est gros avantage sur Ding
pour ce match c'est que lui il a déjà
joué un match il s'est déjà préparé une
fois donc il peut encore se servir de
truc qu'il a regardé et
ok l'autre truc c'est que bending il a
très peu joué il a depuis deux trois ans
à cause du covid il bougeait pas de
Chine
du coup enfin pour moi oui une époque
bien favori du match
même si intrinsèquement je crois pas que
ce soit un meilleur joueur mais sur la
dynamique des dernières années
probablement nettement plus de moyens
financiers pour se préparer ce qui fait
une énorme différence pour ce genre de
match donc il y a vraiment tous les
voyants sont au vert avant le début du
match pour néo il est grand favori mais
des chinois c'est jamais non enfin il
est pas très bien préparé
la Chine ça c'est opaque non ce qui se
passe on sait pas enfin on sait pas de
tout ce que j'ai entendu c'est un petit
peu renseigné de tout ce que j'ai
entendu c'est juste que les échecs pour
eux c'est mais là je crois qu'ils ont
fait une marche arrière
ils ont gagné dans la pierre ils ont eu
une tonne de joueurs 2007 ils ont été
très bon et d'un coup stop
je me suis renseigné du fait que même
sur les joueurs professionnels ils
pensent que c'est mieux même si tes 26
50 ou quoi de d'arrêter les échecs et de
faire des études beaucoup plus important
genre c'est vraiment
les échecs c'est vraiment rien pour en
fait d'avis d'un coup c'est juste que
bon c'est un truc qui sert à rien je
crois qu'ils sont plus sur le GO les
enfin je veux dire un moment j'ai
l'impression ils ont ils ont sorti ok
bah il y avait Ding il y avait oui il y
avait
plutôt leur nom quoi
ils arrêtent tous en fait d'un coup mais
je vais ils ont poussé pour que j'arrive
tout ça en même temps c'est pas le
hasard que ce soit tout cela
ils sont normaux en fait mais j'ai
l'impression que ouais ils ont poussé il
est peut-être dans la pièce c'est bon et
[Musique]
ils ont plein de jeux en fait
évident qu'ils ont pas donné les mêmes
moyens à Digne que
non je pense que pour eux c'est comme
enfin je sais pas c'est comme pour nous
je trouve même pas d'équivalent
[Musique]
je crois pas que ce soit alors après
comme ils ont beaucoup plus de moyens
comme c'est tellement multiplié mais je
pense pas que ce soit quelque chose de
je pense pas que ce soit quelque chose
d'important du tout mais pourquoi pas en
fait ils ont
eu l'impression qu'avant ça a été
important enfin ça a été semi important
mais qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait un
truc ils avaient
vous avez une sorte d'école
ça disparu les mecs ne jouent plus on
les voit plus non non
les machins
[Musique]
du monde il pensait que ça faisait plus
aucun sens parce que tu avais une place
de numéro mondial donc il comprend pas
pourquoi il y a le match en fait il y a
toujours une place
71 il y a ouais mais il a pas enfin pour
moi il a pas le temps ça devrait soit
l'un soit l'autre les deux en même temps
c'est un peu bizarre
[Musique]
non mais écoute mais par contre ils sont
ouais ils sont fort au gauche je crois
avec les Coréens ils se mettent dessus
ça joue bien League of Legends ils sont
quand même derrière la Corée mais tu
vois ils sont pas mal hein bah regarde
le c'est qu'il va y avoir un championnat
il y a même pas toutes les équipes qui
vont mais il va y avoir un truc en
Arabie Saoudite dans l'espace
ils ont des moyens c'est dur de
lutter quoi
un truc aux échecs ils ont organisé le
championnat
championnat arabe
c'était je crois 80 000 au premier et tu
regardes le tournoi non
il y a pas qu'un prix quoi en plus et
alors moi j'ai jamais vu un tournoi où
j'ai joué où il y avait 80000 nos
premiers en fait Gibraltar c'était un
gros truc c'est 20000 et c'était un gros
truc j'aimerais le retard tu avais
vraiment des beaux joueurs
et et c'est quatre fois moins quoi
et c'est plus que 4 fois plus fort enfin
oui bon pourquoi pas
donc il veut mais il veut tourner vite
il doit pas être bien quand même
je me rappelle aussi d'ailleurs mon gars
on a oublié de le rappeler mais les
dernières fois lorsqu'il a joué en
Europe donc il s'est déplacé il est
beaucoup de mal au début on se rappelle
qu'il avait perdu qu'on tenait peau
candidat la première partie
là va il avait bien compris
il a eu beaucoup de mal à se mettre dans
les tournois et c'est pas étonnant pour
quelqu'un qui joue peu d'avoir du mal
les deux trois premières parties à
obtenir son niveau et c'est vrai que ben
là côté n'est pas quand tu vois
l'ouverture qui se passe bien comme ça
et que tu sais que digne il peut être
fragile sur les premières parties là tu
dois à côté des ponts tu dois vraiment
avoir envie de marquer hein
en plus oui enfin
ici il y a une dès la première
j'ai mal au moral
et en plus ce n'est pas
souvent quand il en confiance il joue
mieux en fait il insta quand il perd
mais si ça se passe bien ça se passe
bien quoi avec lui
c'est peut-être déjà un tournant un gros
tournant de championnat du monde cette
première partie Fab passionnant en tout
cas dès le début là on arrive on est
dans le vif du sujet on voit un époque
qui s'est qui s'est assis on le voit pas
voilà c'est juste regarder bien la
caméra dure parce que en fait d'après ce
que ce que j'ai remarqué les caméras bug
un peu donc c'est bien d'avoir les trois
ça nous permet de toujours avoir une un
point de contrôle un point de contrôle
et donc là on voit un peu c'est
effectivement racis et il réfléchit tout
simplement
les deux coups logiques c'est vraiment
H3 pour faire poser la question au fou
ou cavalier C3 je sais pas qui est des
deux
je comprends ouais
[Musique]
donc là je dois bouger le cavalier et à
ce moment-là tu auras peut-être un faux
aussi plus facile
[Musique]
de tourner en plus
et peut-être tu peux je sais pas après
mais la paire de fou elle est peut-être
pas si mal peut-être que je préfère
quand même un peu les blancs finalement
mais ouais mais tu te Soulages un peu
alors que ah 3 sur tour des 8 je pense
tu prends
[Musique]
je sais pas mais tu fais peut-être F3
F2 pression sur H des conneries mais si
tu arrives pas l'agence et tu arrives
pas un pique point final OK
[Applaudissements]
donc H3 tours machin on veut juste
comprendre en fait
mais c'est quoi ça
ah ouais mais bon
[Musique]
inattendu
[Rires]
tu dois pas être bien quand même
juste ça va pas à cause de ça
et donc j'imagine
[Musique]
mais attends je suis en train de
réfléchir un truc
et
donc
H3 3D 8
et 3 et bon ok si on se rend pas le
piège on va dire
parce que ton cavalier il a trompé et ok
tu aurais fait 8 enfin
je prends des quatre et ça va cette fois
j'ai foncé
ça peut aller en réalité
c'est trop mais c'est beau ce qui est
dessiné
[Musique]
3 tu fais tourner 8 mais je pense que
en fait et là quand il réfléchit qui
fait cavalier ces trois tu dis ok
qu'est-ce qui se passe ouais tu regardes
quand même
là obligatoirement dans le scénario de
parti tu es obligé de te dire
d'apprendre des cartes il a une idée et
tu vois qu'il y a eu des cinq mais tu
dois pas être bien quand même
la paramoune de te faire fout ici
il doit pas être bien quand même
c'est mieux d'avoir
de jouer sur échiquier réel pour pour
cette raison là qu'on les a pas en
caméra lorsqu'il joue mais le truc c'est
que tu peux pas trop mystique non
c'est peut-être en fait le seul avantage
d'avoir l'échiquier au milieu du délire
c'est
et si tu fais un mystique tu l'auras
fait aussi sur l'ordi
avoir une narine à la place de dépôt
pendant 3 semaines
écoute
[Musique]
en réalité là c'est juste la caméra qui
ne marche pas parce que nepo est assis
on le voit en bas à droite donc en soit
on devrait voir un dépôt à sa place mais
je sais pas pourquoi ça fonctionne pas
je vais peut-être essayer de la relance
peu importe on va pas passer notre temps
à parler de caméra ça a pas grand
intérêt
mais finalement j'aime mieux les photos
moi que voir ça quand même
désolé c'était pas prévu
c'est compliqué
je peux pas passer à ma vie à commenter
des caméras à me remettre à remettre
c'est désagréable pour les gens qui
écoutent donc
on va faire ce qu'on peut
en tout cas il est concentré bon la Dame
des 7 je pense qu'il l'a pas
relativement vite jusqu'à maintenant
tant qu'il se rappeler et là Dame des 7
mais bon pas facile d'avoir parce que
s'ils ont vu que fougères c'était pas la
même Dame des 7 il faut qu'il ait vu
dans son fichier l'idée de 5%. mais si
il a pas vu c'est pas évident
mais non c'est dur à trouver enfin genre
c'est vraiment dur après donc oui sinon
je te prennent pas ils font des deux
tours au centre je sais même pas à quel
point tu es à quel point tu es mieux
quoi
en fait nous on n'aurait pas compris
qu'on était mieux de base déjà non mais
faut dire la vérité c'est un peu nous on
a eu le truc bon on savait pas prendre
on était mieux donc forcément si tu
trouves pas les coups ça me fait penser
un truc que d'en parler guéri et parfois
tu as des très longs prépa et l'avantage
il est tellement ordinateur s que même
si tu as plus 0,4 ben tu peux pas faire
en fait tu peux pas le transformer mais
donc là on est pas complètement dans
quelque chose comme ça parce qu'on voit
quand même que si tu trouves quelques
coups tu vas quand même mettre en danger
qu'il y avait des variantes qui étaient
un peu dangereuses mais c'est vrai que
contre des coups humains logiques de
dingly Rennes il t'en faut encore
quelques-uns côté des pots pour vraiment
avoir quelque chose qu'on peut
transformer cependant il faut aussi dire
que le point positif de cette repète
nepo c'est qu'au pire s'il trouve pas
les meilleurs coups qui vont vraiment
lui permettre d'avoir un avantage
conversible il sera pas moins bien donc
il prend aucun risque
il trouve les bons coups il va y arriver
il trouve pas les bons coups il va rien
lui arriver de mal
bon après c'est
[Musique]
c'est bien pour
le suspense pour le suspense c'est même
pour le match que finalement il se passe
souvenir de tout quoi
et que encore jouer des coups logiques
humains tu sois pas obligé de perdre à
chaque fois quoi
tant que ça vibre pas oui
le jour où tu auras les vibrante
c'est fini mais c'est toute la
difficulté alors là il y a pas de
il y a pas de triche ou quoi que ce soit
mais c'est pour ça que c'est un sujet
aussi difficile quand vous nous entendez
c'est qu'en fait là il pourrait très
bien t'envoyer qu'à il s'est 3h je me
rappelle de mon fichier
jusqu'au bout une très bonne mémoire
et c'est fini tu fermes le jeu mais bon
là il y a le les sécurités contre ça son
maximal généralement ça va jusqu'au
brouilleur enfin ça va très très loin là
pour pour les matchs comme celui-là donc
c'est enfin une compétition on est
vraiment tranquille à ce niveau là
et ça peut
se ressentir de par les coûts
en tout cas partie sympa première partie
sympathique Fab bon ça joue un peu enfin
ça joue il y a une partie
[Musique]
qu'on a pas tous les jours c'est pas
juste en réussite en récitée
quand même jusqu'à maintenant j'ai envie
de dire très intéressant te Fab ouais
franchement bien
partie sympathique agréable
mais donc on va voir s'il trouve dans le
vif du sujet aussi il faut dire parfois
il nous arrive enfin il va nous arriver
dans championnat du monde d'avoir des
parties ou pendant deux heures voire
même trois heures tu es toujours plus ou
moins dans les prépas que on reste
vraiment à la limite de prépa et là
c'est vrai qu'on a une partie on est
rentré dans le vif du sujet après après
15-20 minutes de jeu ce qui est quand
même relativement rare et c'est agréable
à suivre c'est très vite devenu humain
comme parti vite vite sorti de je me
rappelle je me rappelle pas je
reconstruis mon fichier etc là c'est
plus le cas là c'est jeu de check ma
coupe de cheveux
il a pas son chignon
chignonnais
ça réfléchit ça va bientôt être notre
petite pause chez sarama qui est un des
partenaires Fab de cet événement
d'ailleurs c'est extraordinaire tu peux
faire du foot et des échecs en même
temps c'est à des parties d'échecs sur
des terrains de foot
[Applaudissements]
sarahma que tu vois là
est-ce que tu penses c'est pas le mot
pause chez sarahma je pense que c'est
Laurent chez sarahma allez maman c'est
ça Rama donc on y va on fait une petite
pause commerciale et on attend le coup
de ne pas voir s'il trouve
l'extraordinaire cavalissait trois
cavaliers des 5 à tout de suite l'élite
à tout de suite monte chez Sarah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
gros stade de dépôt
qui s'est passé encore une dingue avec
la caméra mais on est retour au bon
moment puisqu'il a joué le cavalier C3
prévu voilà parfait il y a eu le
cavalier C3 qui est parti Fab ok
ça fait pas trop de sens
qu'il a retrouvé peut-être qu'il a
retrouvé
peut-être qu'il a retrouvé peut-être pas
en tout cas il s'est il arrive
parce que ok tu auras des 8 s'il fait
pas je trouve que il se barre en béton
on peut regarder vite en partant du
principe que tu fasses pas je crois
bon ok
puis on prend et tu tapes
le contrôle de la case E6 en quelque
sorte
maintenant faut garder F5 alors je sais
pas dommage 3 peut-être
non
complexe
mais oui non toi c'est pas simple
enfin je sais pas trop conduire mais
ok mais bon je suis pas sûr tout ça
mieux que les Blancs quoi on va dire
et
ouais mais c'est logique enfin il a fait
tout ça pour ça mais en gros soit ça va
aller là-dedans soit il va faire 3
[Musique]
en gros c'est soit H3 qui doit être le
meilleur j'imagine avec le meilleur
le seul coup pour avantage 3 je crois
après bon ce qu'on a regardé qui F5
c'est une position intéressante je sais
pas qui est mieux
[Musique]
et j'ai 4 qui part et de compagnie oui
mais je parle vraiment pour un montage
clair
on est mieux quoi
moi non plus j'ai pas compris
parce que je sais pas mais non mais ce
dont je suis sûr c'est que si tu fais H3
c'est quand même un coup de boutoir pour
pour dim ça te fait mal la tête
quand même le H3 te fait mal parce que
ça m'étonnerait qu'il ait vu de me
prendre des quatre qui est des 5 quand
même non
après ils sont forts le mec c'est final
champion du monde mais ça me paraît
voilà savoir que sur H3 tu as pas
d'apprendre des quatre ça me paraît
tellement dur tu t'yttends pas oui
pour moi là le coup à venir là je suis
très curieux là je suis très satisé ma
curiosité il est là bon c'est la cam de
contrôle qui marche plus mais bon
on a un freeze dans une position assez
marrante il fait une petite image c'est
cool
est vraiment très dur
moi
0,14
donc oui c'est pas si gros avantage
quand je voyais la ligne mais pourquoi
c'est si bien enfin je
j'ai du mal à capter quoi
voilà je sais pas je sens plus partir ce
weekend
[Musique]
on va voir
mais bon
[Musique]
il a joué quand même que des coups
normaux oui c'est ça
il y a pas eu un coup bizarre
je suis pas sûr mais bon faut des temps
logique et bon j'ai pas trop
et
je sais pas
individu genre free frites
[Musique]
genre même ça bah oui
je te casse un truc là dessus je
commence à m'infiltrer
enfin mieux au noir non c'est pas
vraiment ce que je voulais pas le dire
comme ça mais est-ce que ça devient pas
danger
réciproque
parce que je vois pas les blancs serait
mieux là en réalité non non mais je sais
pas non plus
[Musique]
si on fait G4 direct
peut-être c'est un truc comme ça tu as
raison
ok à voir si un ordi on trouve un
avantage parce que c'est que 0,16 en
fait c'est que c'est rien
mais quelque part bonne nouvelle que
comme je te dis que les couilles humains
ça va se passer quoi
direct
[Musique]
ok oui
ça a l'air d'être juste rien oui donc en
fait n'est pas eu raison de pas ton
tonton
[Musique]
avec le chat on sait pas du tout de
quelle position maximale c'était quand
on a changé toutes les tours là
[Musique]
enfin j'ai 4 on va dire l'autre sens
mais on s'en fout Tourer
à cause de Dam G3 c'est top c'est ça
aussi
[Musique]
mais ça a pas l'air d'être assez quand
même
[Musique]
et je sais pas en fait notre vie quoi
trop ça du mal à juger le danger truc
comme ça
tu as l'impression que c'est rien mais
c'est peut-être un une erreur de ma part
la peut-être enfin moi aussi je
préférerais les blancs quand je vois
cette finale là mais
donc prise prise tout revu GK x F6 dans
H3 ouais ou c'est dommage
[Musique]
mais c'est moins appuyé moins marqué que
plutôt
[Musique]
ici
et pourquoi pas un dragon sur internet
de foot en fait
tu peux te faire matrixer par le jeu
tu peux jouer les Verts contre je sais
pas quoi je l'ai vu contre les Bleus ça
va faire des PSG santé c'est comme un
fou quoi pourquoi
même pas regardé
[Musique]
pourquoi pas après qui avait lu aussi il
va là où on voulait le mettre depuis le
début mais
mais
c'est bizarre enfin en fait sans trop
rien calculer ou quoi j'aurais préféré
l'autre ligne qu'on regarde avec les
pions F5 enfin faut prendre si on prend
côté noir que là je me dis je vais faire
qui est princesse
noir hein
[Musique]
après à moins qu'il y ait des quatre
très fort je sais pas quoi mais
pour l'instant qu'on peut peut-être
travailler avec les reposer là
quand l'adversaire a une majorité à la
loi ça veut dire que pour moi
pas moins qu'il est le truc d'ordi F5
c'est quand même assez thématique dans
ce truc bien sûr c'est pas un coup
bizarre mais je veux dire c'est juste
qu'avec le placement de pièces il faut
bien un truc sur la colonne ou mais
rien
[Musique]
ça me saoule tout le temps devant mon
roi quand j'ai foutu le reposer mais
[Musique]
si je compare les deux
concrètement NP mais c'est peut-être la
position elle est désagréable
[Musique]
après quand tu joues pas tu as toujours
du mal à
c'est mon truc quoi
[Musique]
on est un peu des girouettes quand même
bah oui
c'est terrible en fait le niveau des
commentaires là c'est affligeant quoi
non mais pour le coup enfin ça change
aussi
[Musique]
on se pose des questions quand on
s'interroge on ne sait pas
mais je suis d'accord avec toi j'aime
pas cette histoire de de majorité là
elle a le droit avec les footballeurs
opposés mais
un résultat c'est vrai qu'une ferait
plaisir c'est champion du monde moi
j'espère 14 nuls seulement
non mais je pense que ce serait beau
quoi 14 mais j'y crois pas trop non vu
les styles on va pas y arriver mais moi
j'espère nul à chaque partie tant qu'il
y a des nuls je suis heureux mais
j'espère vraiment 14 affiliés parce
qu'en fait ça va faire monter live à la
dernière partie enfin tu vois plus le
match va avancer serait égalité le
premier qui gagne gagnera donc ce sera
vraiment le chaque cours a de plus en
plus dangereux
donc si on peut réussir à faire 14,14
parties moi ce serait mon rêve et en
fait j'aimerais bien qu'il y a encore
des nuls pour les départages rapides
[Musique]
ce serait bon non mais ouais ça me fait
penser ce qui est une équipe de foot qui
a déjà gagné un tournoi sans gagner un
match
00 les trois premiers matchs je sais pas
c'était 300 mais après il y a quand même
gagné des matchs mais juste une gaine
jamais en fait que des tirs au but et
t'écrase et tu marques même jamais de
but tu fais que des 00
il n'y avait pas eu un peu de Portugal
dans Strange quand il avait gagné l'euro
et pas eu beaucoup de match nuls là de
tir au but
bon parce qu'elles nous ont battus
[Musique]
il va jouer
tous les jours frérot
ouais
je suis quand même là
il a vraiment que deux coups
je vais essayer quand même de remettre
la grande la grande cam j'y arrive
on s'attend à Fougères
qui pour le coup est pas obligatoire
mais semble logique
et ça se passe que ils veulent
être impatient de notre on va essayer de
passer comme ça
désolé c'est un peu compliqué le
problème c'est comme les caméras
marchent pas bien
de part et d'autre
j'ai pas aimé la décision là mais je
peux peut-être comprendre enfin
peut-être que il y a un truc qu'on a pas
regardé sur
[Musique]
en fait
c'est le nez
et il s'est levé là comme si donc
c'est celle de Ding qu'on arrive plus à
voir ou qui était tout flou et la grande
angle
la cadence
60 minutes de rajouts
de 6 ans et demi de jeu plus les 30
secondes n'oublions pas non qu'on peut
aller au 7 8 heures peut-être si genre
sont en forme dans les grands jours
ouais donc je disais enfin je disais je
disais rien mais oui peut-être qu'il y a
5 vous prend puis on prend il avait peur
d'un F6 qui tombe dessus quoi
[Musique]
mais du coup vaut mieux pousser ça
essayer d'égaliser si tu arrives pas
toujours l'autre mais
[Musique]
parce que là j'ai l'impression que tu es
moins bien justement bien quoi
à quel point je sais pas mais que ça
peut pousser enfin moi je serai pas à
l'aise avec une position
mais je veux dire j'ai déjà eu
je sais plus ce que c'était une Anglaise
une partie et
c'était beaucoup moins pire que ça parce
que les blancs et pas de pioncer et moi
j'avais qu'un pioncé avec le noir mais
déjà ça me saoule
par là-bas il te regarde le roi et puis
on peut partir j'avais fait nul mais
j'aimais pas jamais quoi tout le long de
la partie
si tu veux un truc je sais pas combien
tu peux t'arriver dessus en permanence
long terme quelque chose d'attente à une
épée de Damoclès qui est là
donc tu vas avoir du mal toi de créer du
jeu de l'autre côté non j'aime pas non
plus
ma propre objectif
ouais mais faut bien défendre longtemps
quoi ça on est d'accord mais je veux
juste te dire par là que objectivement
sur je veux parfait tu perds pas
ouais parce que
oui
c'est pénible j'aimerais pas trop non
plus mais bon tu peux aussi te rassurer
en disant bon écoute après je sais pas
parce que si on fait joue l'ordi qu'on
soit ordi ils font 100% de
nuls cette position
moi je sais pas mais bon
non mais si évidemment je serai pas je
serai pas Aria ravi de la partie mais
je serais pas non plus en train de me
dire avec les Noirs bon je suis au bord
du précipice quoi généralement on va
mettre deux trois barbeles on va la
tenir
même
non mais j'aurais quand même déçu de
faire ça ça peut mal se passer ça déçu à
la fin si je perceuse
je me sentirais quand même favori pour
la tenir c'est tout ce que je dis
je peux la perdre mais
[Musique]
j'aurais dit ça
je sais pas ce que toi tu te dirais mais
moi j'aurais dit ça
je me serais dit ça plutôt
bon je le dirai pourquoi j'ai pas
pris un bail quoi qu'est-ce que je fais
là quoi c'est
plus ou moins logique tu mets les pions
sur blanc ça bloque le fou ça renforce 4
ça bloque pour tourner un
ça te permet de repasser le fou si
jamais un F2 ou d'un F2
j'ai 4 ça peut être
tu lances un peu dessus après il fait
plus son F5 et on avance gentiment quoi
F6
j'envoie j'envoie mon fou je renvoie mon
fou quelque part et vraiment j'aimerais
bien
tu vois
c'est bien qu'on va voir
mais
[Musique]
le tour des 7 tours
je te laisse faire ton G4 et j'essaye de
faire un truc de faire un truc là-bas
le truc c'est que tu me fais 5 je fais 5
je te préviens
non mais je préfère te dire
je me dis que j'ai mes deux puntos là
qui te bloquent la diagonale
donc je suis très heureux de ça et si tu
avances je te ferme après je peux
avancer tout le monde quoi
j'ai 4 H 4 F5
je repars par là enfin
non mais on voit enfin
[Musique]
je me demanderais comme toi pourquoi
j'ai pas pris de bail
par exemple une tous les trois jours non
deux tous les trois jours pardon
des fois une tous les trois jours
préféré du championnat c'est bon ça va
jouer enfin il va y avoir jour de repos
on va jouer un jour et souffle bien ce
qu'on a vu la septième partie donc là
forcément dans un tournant et
le septième jeu de service en fait
c'est sympa moi j'aime bien ces jours de
repos au milieu ça permet de souffler un
peu
non mais tu rigoles mais il y a beaucoup
de part quand même
ce qu'on veut montrer le début de la
partie complètement voilà on a le temps
frérot tu sais
c'est une Espagnole
qui se transforme une sorte d'espagnol
d'échange tu vois
tac tac
et voilà tu vas reconnaître la position
très vite ça peut être tellement de coup
de jouer finalement mais
non il y a pas eu énormément de coups
mais il est beaucoup
on voit c'est des jolies coups dans
cette partie
c'est le match pour le titre est
complètement
non c'est bien c'est une partie
intéressante
[Musique]
les finales sont pas si nuls
si on échange tout peut-être mais
une tour ou quoi c'est pas la même et tu
as toujours ce problème sur ces 7 quand
même attends long terme il peut être
chiant mais
il est tellement il est dur à chasser
hein et d'ailleurs peut-être les blancs
ça peut être
[Musique]
bon ils sont fous complètement
mais je crois que c'est chiant
un moment peut-être on va te rendre
passif on va devoir faire tourner pour
défendre qu'on va te rentrer la colonne
des je sais pas mais qui a un truc comme
ça
plus le fait que nous on peut faire un
pion passé
donc je pense pas qu'il change les dames
tu as envie mais par contre
[Musique]
je sais pas ce soir
vraiment
la suite en fait
ça rendra peut-être beaucoup plus
évident dans dans 20 minutes
à poster Henry on pourra dire ah oui ok
mais c'est juste que ouais c'est pas on
les aurait pas joué de manière aussi
facile parce que c'est vrai que les gens
jouer relativement vite comme si c'était
vraiment très logique après ils sont
plus fort que nous donc
c'est pas évident
après en soit oui ils vont être tous les
pions sur la couleur à poser de leur fou
donc le foot vient ça bloque un peu le
fou adverse
je comprends le fond du truc mais
je le comprends aussi mais pourquoi
acheter c'est mieux que ton dessin
de jouer à 6 bon on verra et si on doit
le faire donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un
truc qu'on a pas compris
ce qui est normal oui et on serait nous
qui serait en train de jouer donc
des skis jouit toi et moi je trouve
qu'il joue relativement vite
alors on a de nouveau la caméra
d'ensemble qui marche
on n'est pas bien ouais on arrive pas à
avoir de les caméras bon après faut dire
c'est pas facile non plus hein c'est
quand même voilà c'est une technologie
un petit peu capricieuse le flux vidéo
c'est nouveau donc ouais c'est pas c'est
pas non mais c'est pas simple tu as
beaucoup de d'ordinateurs qui sont
connectés dessus et le flux vidéo c'est
vraiment pas quelque chose de simple moi
je le fais tous les soirs
donc je sais c'est pas envoyé un flux
vidéo sur internet c'est pas quelque
chose de forcément évident et on le voit
ici hein
ok ils vont éviter des dames c'est cinq
ou quoi mais comme on l'a vu c'est pas
vraiment une menace mais il doit dire
qu'il a le temps en réalité
si l'idée c'est de se faire F2 G4 et
coulisser mais là je m'y fou F2
maintenant j'ai Dame des six mais je
crois qu'on comprend rien en fait donc
je
[Musique]
tu crois qu'on comprend vraiment rien
Fab
enfin c'est pas des coups qu'on comprend
pas mais c'est juste qu'on comprend pas
pourquoi ils sont si évidents et
pourquoi il y en a repéré la cam
non parce que je veux dire c'est que oui
c'est une position
il y a pas de clash concret quoi donc tu
peux prendre ton temps d'améliorer mais
je sais pas ce qu'il améliore pour
l'instant j'ai pas envie que ce roi moi
je mets bien en fait comme plan alors
t'es pas obligé de jouer en deux coups
mais comme idée l'attente dans c'est à
cet endroit prendre l'espace c'est
l'acte à majorité de façon tu avances là
du coup qu'est-ce qu'il y a un
jeu loin
allez c'est l'enchaînement genre H3 H6
3G en mode
bah oui
F2
on est sur d'autres objectifs quoi
mais
oui ce qui est bien c'est que ça va
c'est clair et petit à petit donc là
pour l'instant on suit mais on va
comprendre on va comprendre on pourra
faire un beau résumé après
là on est pas on n'a pas le niveau
j'ai 5 genre complètement normal
genre
tu es là oui bon j'ai cinko et puis j'ai
mal à l'autre fait roche
pourquoi pas
tout il te défonce quoi
c'est trop
beau ils sont en train de penser au
Dragon de chez sarahma qui crache du feu
que ça fait une batterie ça fait un truc
quoi de frappe en fait après tout d'un
coup
[Musique]
il a refait pas voir là
une belle frappa
il a une belle frappe
pour comprendre
ce qui passe à tout moment on sait pas
les trois heures trois heures de
décalage je crois
j'essaie de choper des infos sur Twitter
des fois s'il te mette ce que commentent
les anglais ce qui raconte je veux dire
des infos mais non là ils te disent les
commentaires anglais c'est très
intéressant là mais ils savent pas trop
ce qui va se passer ici
mais c'est pas mal enfin on est là en
mode
spectateur quoi
mais bon j'aime mieux ma position
blanche voilà moi je peux l'acheter
cette info là
c'est pas l'info la plus dure que tu as
eu à lâcher ah mais quand même je prends
un téléphone
qui marche pas je peux essayer de la
remettre une fois mais
ça marche pas
précieuse le flux vidéo et voilà ça
marche pas aujourd'hui ça marchera
peut-être demain alors attends c'est
peut-être revenu
[Musique]
il est pas là
en fait on se fait chier mais on le voit
jamais en fait parce que il reste plus
là
[Musique]
et donc il vient juste jouer son coup et
repartir en général
donc oui on peut mettre la caméra pour
voir le nuage de fumée
bon mais là ça remarche ça va ne pas
marcher mais là ça marche un petit peu
mais quand je vois ça je me dis vraiment
que de le fait de jouer sur ordinateur
c'est pas si bête tu vois quand on dit
ouais mais c'est mieux sur un échiquier
réel des échecs etc bon tu vois la
finale Championnat du Monde ah ben moi
je préfère
ça se fait quand même économiser tu vois
l'empreinte carbone du tournoi tu prends
un truc de Crécy vite mais le nom
d'avions de machin de déplacement de
tout après je dois pour l'hybride faut
quand même venir
l'hybride on est quand même là on te
regarde faire quoi j'ai pas trop
confiance
internationaux enfin où tu as joué qui
est du monde enfin c'était juste avec un
arbitre chez toi
mais en soi enfin là on est déjà on est
quand même proche je dois dire d'un
championnat du monde hybride déjà
puisque les joueurs sont quand même plus
enfin regard de plus les parties depuis
l'écran de desiottes ou de la ressembles
donc quelque part pour moi on est
vraiment sur un championnat hybride
quand tu fais une réfléchis pas devant
l'échiquier
c'est réel non mais enfin
on est on est déjà plus sur des échecs
qui jouent sur eshi et pour moi là ce
championnat du monde comme le précédent
ne se joue pas sur l'échiquier
il était plus là mais alors là celui-là
il ne se joue pas sur les chic et je
suis désolé il se joue sur un écran
depuis un canapé quoi j'essaye de
refaire le grand angle où on voit la
table vide quoi
quand même
elle est pas mis
on a énormément de mal à l'avoir en
direct
non mais je sais pas quoi tous les
championnats du monde un peu mythique
les mecs c'était pas là se barrer tout
le temps quoi
des photos ils sont là-dedans de salle
de contrôle
et qui veut savoir Sa vie de jouer tu
mets tu mets juste un truc blanc noir ou
tu vois la pendule qui sous-trait quoi
et encore tu as qu'à savoir enfin car
quand tu joues un tournoi
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est une balade c'est ton
problème tu reviens tu viens checker
c'est à toi ou pas
en tout cas
quoi qu'on en pense le fait avec le fait
que c'est comme ça qu'on soit d'accord
avec qu'on soit d'accord pas d'accord
qu'on est notre notre opinion en réalité
notre opinion veut pas grand chose mais
mais la réalité est la suivante c'est
que c'est que les joueurs passent
nettement plus de temps à regarder la
position depuis un écran 2D que sur les
chic et en 3D donc pour moi on est dans
un champion du monde déjà hybride un Fab
enfin c'est
pour moi c'est en fait
ils ont quand même poussé le truc
il évite le
il a des connexions
alors caméra peut ne pas être
bon après peut-être tu fais mal ton
lacets tu tombes je sais pas enfin par
d'autres problèmes mais bon toujours en
hybride avec deux heures 40 minutes
machin et tout
tu pourrais ne pas avoir de déco ici
imagine les hackers russes rentrent en
action quoi tu sais pas
non mais là ils vont pas aux toilettes
ils sont vraiment sur le sofa du truc il
dit les toilettes mais en fait c'est pas
ils sont pas aux toilettes ils sont
juste il y a juste une autre salle où
ils ont à bouffer ou ils ont un canapé
et où ils sont assis quoi
mais oui tu te dis si tu es juste
spectateur live que tu achètes ta place
pour
ça j'imagine qu'est-ce que tu viens voir
en fait
ouais mais écoute c'est comme ça c'est
une évolution mais oui c'est
les évolution les évolutions sont pas
toujours bien
ça dépend qu'il est réalise
c'est pas pour autant que c'est mieux
une évolution n'est pas forcément un
progrès quoi en tout cas la backup
c'était cool
et ça sera cool encore une fois ouais
c'est un peu en avance dessus quoi c'est
un peu ouais on peut 15-20 ans d'avance
[Musique]
il revient il sait ce qu'il va jouer à
mon avis
moi on va le voir ça va être net si si
il joue dans les 20 30 secondes
ou alors on est mauvaise langue non non
mais c'est sûr
quoi non mais c'est sûr qu'il va jouer
il peut pas ne pas être là jamais quoi
on va le voir si si il joue dans les
dans les deux minutes oui mais sinon
c'est peut-être juste qui on sait quoi
il y a un truc
je connais pas les règles mais
[Musique]
avant tu n'avais pas le droit de te
relever
parfois tu sais quand tu penses que ton
adversaire triche tu as regardé sur
internet imagine 4 figure tu tapes le
long de ton adversaire et tu vois qu'il
a un compte il a triché sur Internet ah
bah ouais ça arrive et après tu joues en
réel donc tu dis tiens c'est un tricheur
de merde ça et du coup tu joues tout
tempo pour pas qu'il aille tu vois aux
toilettes prendre un café ou quoi c'est
bien normal mais ça ça arrive parfois
non mais ça arrive
bah dis donc il était complètement
normal si on me prévient alors soit que
je fasse ma recherche tout seul ou qu'on
me dise tiens fais gaffe un tel machin
tu vois pas qui se lève en fait
je veux pas qu'il fasse derrière et aime
bien sûr tu restes assis tu la fermes
enfin oui ça ça a pu arriver ça peut
arriver que tes joueurs qui joue tempo
parce qu'ils ont vu ok le compte le mec
a triché et tu dis ok juste je vais le
laisser assis je vais tout éteindre le
mec est nul et je le bat mais ça ça peut
être le cas et c'est c'est pour ça qu'il
y a des joueurs qui peuvent le faire
mais c'est rare ici mais du coup le
problème c'est que tu te mets un peu
dans la merde comme tu joues tout tempo
pour le laisser assis peut-être tu
baisses ton niveau aussi mais je préfère
jouer quelqu'un humain tempo que de
toute façon ça c'est clair
ça peut arriver
mais bon de toute façon c'est pas une
sensation agréable de jouer contre un
tricheur tu sais pas s'il va tricher
cette partie là mais tu as le doute il
peut faire il a déjà fait il peut faire
sur Internet c'est très désagréable tu
es sûr à 100 % c'est très désagréable
non mais je veux dire si tu as déjà
triché c'est pas la barrière morale sur
Internet ou n'importe où c'est que tu es
capable quoi donc c'est problématique
donc ça ça peut arriver des fois que tu
as des gens qui jouent vite pour ça pour
éviter
mais donc normalement quand c'est à toi
de jouer tu as plus le droit de te
relever donc tu es bloqué tu es bloqué
sur la table
d'où l'utilité d'avoir une bouteille
vide quand même
bouteille vert
et bouteille vide
finalement il joue le coup qu'on
avançait depuis tout à l'heure normal et
sur celui-là il a mis plus de temps que
sur le H6 qu'on pensait si tu as le
temps de faire
en tout cas il compte plus faire F5 là a
priori j'ai tout ce qui joue
il va faire F4 non mais vraiment avec
les blancs du coup là je crois que tu as
le temps de bricoler
pas le temps tu peux faire aussi
d'un F2 qui avait des un caillot 3 tu te
replaces
mais c'est comme souvent dans ces trucs
là faut quand même être très précis
parce qu'à un moment donné il peut y
avoir un coup noir tu vois qui vient un
peu
franchement
très heureux d'avoir les blancs
parce que je sens que tu as pas trop à
calculer
tu places bien tes pièces avant ce petit
à petit si tu te trompes au pire bon bah
merde bon bah c'est nul en fait mais tu
es pas
doté quand même tranquille quoi je sais
pas si ils seront HD il est mieux placé
ce que je suis en train de me dire si je
te fais le plan avec toi des 7 tours des
8 tours des deux bon si j'arrive c'est
pas sûr tu me clou mais bon ouais bon en
réalité parce que j'ai une pièce qui
clou bon merci au revoir mais
après je me dis peut-être les blondes tu
es content de changer une tour
un tour D1 quand l'autre il te fait
tourner cette tourner ton échanger et
pas deux par contre
c'est sûr que tu es content
n'est pas il est nettement plus sur
l'échiquier en revanche que lors de son
champion du monde précédent non mais je
crois qu'il serait trop ouais mais
finalement est-ce que c'est pas ça le
problème de Ding là le stress
ok là je veux pas savoir j'ai jamais
joué un truc à ce niveau mais j'ai même
que la première fois que tu es là quand
même tu sens le poids de l'histoire tu
sens tu sens un truc quoi enfin
l'histoire pèse lourd je pense
c'est une chape de plomb sur les épaules
c'est lourd
une chape de laiton par exemple une
chape de plume
et pour l'autre c'est un peu une chance
inespéré d'être champion du monde enfin
une espérée mais beaucoup plus grosse
que le système Magnus en face et
donc je sais pas tu as pas envie de
faire de la merde quand tu as une telle
opportunité
tu as pas envie
donc mais c'est vrai que on sent que que
les Pomi hachis ils tirent vraiment
profit de son expérience dans le premier
match
et ça c'est quand même important à
souligner à noter
ben en fait c'est toujours une
interrogation que j'avais là pendant
longtemps
pour tous les matchs de champion du
monde contre Magnus attendait
c'est challenger c'était que lui il
avait déjà une expérience a déjà que
c'est un meilleur joueur mais en plus il
a déjà joué des matchs c'est ce que
c'est et chacun arrivait à ses nouveaux
il veut pas enfin il y avait pas
vraiment ça avant ouais ou il y avait
les matchs des candidats il y avait plus
la tradition des matchs non
je trouve que là le cycle est très
illogique avec les lots le fait qu'il y
ait pas de match je trouve que tout le
cycle en soi est complètement illogique
ce que tu sélectionnes des gens via des
tournois pour une compétition finale qui
est par match donc
en fait mais voilà je raconte Fisher il
est arrivé qu'on se passe qui bon bah il
a dû faire ses matchs et candidats où il
a mis ses zéro tout ça tu as une finale
des candidats tu joues petroscien en
face à deux chauffe quand même tu joues
tu joues pas des plots quoi donc tu
commences à avoir d'habitude de préparer
spécifiquement c'est comme si on jouait
toute la saison de tennis en nombre de
points qui gagnent de les matchs
je te propose qu'on s'embête pas trop
longtemps sur cette nouvelle sur cette
conversation puisque c'est l'heure de la
respiration on va respirer et on revient
dans une petite dizaine de minutes en
espérant avoir vu le coup de Yann et
pomyachi on vous laisse avec de la
musique palpitante allez bonne musique à
tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
et voilà le Fab il y a eu il y a eu deux
coups et on est on est revenu un peu au
bon moment là la préparation qui est en
train d'avancer donc il y a eu tout
radin le coup qu'on attendait comme tu
le disais pour échanger une paire de de
tourelle les tomates qui vont être
échangés et B6 bah il essaye de faire
une expansion oh peut-être pour se
donner la case des 4 éventuellement
et j'ai l'impression de ne pas jouer
mais on n'a pas le coup ou alors la
caméra en décalé
mais j'ai l'impression pour moi il a
enfin ouais moi je l'ai vu jouer je l'ai
vu jouer un coup qui était pas
tourradéen donc pour moi il a joué mais
il est quand même ont disparu
donc on va on va voir le Fab
on va voir le Fab comment
comment ça évolue
en fait ce n'est pas évident c'est de
donner des ventes concrètes pour
expliquer complètement ce qui se passe
mais basiquement
c'est la structure en fait foot couleur
opposé favorise la taille 4 pions pour
les blancs à l'endroit 3 pions à l'aile
à l'ail droit pour les Noirs donc
forcément si ça s'échange c'est le roi
noir qui va être le plus en danger et
les Noirs ont du mal à envoyer leur
majorité donc c'est
c'est pas comme il y a pas il y a pas de
vendre concret et il y a tout un tas de
coups qui peuvent même un coup comme à
trois pour contrer la casse B4 tu
pourrais jouer à trois tu peux jouer F4
tu peux jouer même roi j'ai un revenir
ça va rien changer au schmilblick non
non c'est long terme c'est long terme
donc on va voir il va essayer d'avancer
petit à petit mais il est pas tapis dans
l'ombre non mais
j'en sais rien je sais pas si c'est un
vrai ou pas ce que j'ai mais j'aurais
l'impression qu'il changeait un cahier
c'est bien pour les blancs
attends ça va mais je sais pas je trouve
du bon taf il contrôle beaucoup de cases
défenses faut y aller donc
tu vois
il permet aux autres pièces de se
mobiliser s'il est pas là
que j'ai réussi à te une tour là
allez changer machin à mieux me placer à
échanger les dames à filer ces sept et à
faire B5 je montre
le scénario à la con je sais que tu sais
lequel scénario on parle complètement
scénario à la con
scénario à la con scénario à la con donc
bref
scénario là qui a le scénario à la con
admettons qu'on essaie de position
ça c'est nul
mais ça c'est nul donc ça faut qu'il
évite quand même non mais je voudrais ça
mais du coup c'est pour ça que je me dis
si je fais que
[Musique]
passe ton tour
ça je pense que je suis très heureux
et ouais et ça je crois qu'on peut
arriver à travailler
[Musique]
mais là pour le coup je me dis ok je
commence à doubler sur la colonne des
bon tu vas faire aussi tu vas empêcher
mais peut-être un moment j'arrive à te
faire
mais en fait en gros c'est pas le pion
aussi ouais c'est ça
mais à vrai dire même ça en fait ça va
ce que je vais te récupérer
comme ça mais au pire même dans la ligne
qu'on regardait quand tu mets sur une
tote il fait tourner 8 peut-être je
refuse et je fais je sais pas un tour 1
tour quelque part
et qu'après je vais essayer de ramener
le fond E1 C3 et peut-être faire ça
enfin
bref en gros c'est que des trucs j'ai
l'impression que je suis à faire avec
les cavaliers parce que tu me sautes en
Descartes tu me prends des cages je peux
pas faire de la F4 enfin ça
ouais c'est complexe
au bout d'un moment là je pense c'est
vraiment des positions
en fait on peut rien dire de plus que
bah voilà les objectifs
si je dis de la merde enfin
[Musique]
aussi s'il faut garder le cavalier en
fait parce que très bien ça c'est ouais
mais ça c'est on saura enfin on saura
peut-être jamais
[Musique]
non mais on sait rien enfin on sait pas
en gros mais peut-être même sa femme
cette personne sait comment tu ne sais
pas
enfin je suis complètement con mais ce
qu'on fait des dessins
[Musique]
tu vas faire nul comme ça
c'est encore une autre fille c'est la
même un peu différent mais c'est la même
c'est la même
et il a fait à 3 mais c'est ça
j'ai pas envie de dire à rien mais
presque à rien et il les enchaîne quoi
mon grand à trois bon bah
maintenant il veut quoi si tu fais genre
tour des un tour des un tour des un tour
de nuit
[Musique]
si là il échange bon bah il échange mais
je me dis qu'on réduit nos chances de
[Musique]
comprendre comment tu finis c'est triste
quand même je vois pas comment tu peux
pousser ça
parce que de toute façon
je vois pas les blancs gagner ça en fait
j'en rêve 4 il y a des cases je vois pas
les blancs gagner ça
[Musique]
même avec les Blancs et puis le 5 et
puis je sais pas quoi
non non
voilà peut-être c'est déjà trop tard
mais peut-être on va y arriver peut-être
pas peut-être bon mais bon
avec toi mais
c'est quand même pas grand chose
qui doit penser que en fait ça va te
reprendre
c'est une autre option
tellement pas je sais pas moi
[Musique]
est-ce que tu es content d'avoir
renforcer
je pense pas en fait mais
c'est un peu triste
en fait je veux une tour au moins quoi
est-ce que tu peux prendre du cheval
[Musique]
bon quelque part j'enlève la dame ça je
sais pas où et qui
et ça c'était une option
mais bon ça est-ce que tu redonnes
[Musique]
elles sont un peu rentrées pour
s'activer et c'est
il y a pas assez de jeu donc en fait je
pense c'est ça l'idée c'est tout
franchement c'est pas tout reprendre
c'est cavaliers franchement
et pour repartir comme tu le disais vers
E3 c'est pour ça qu'il fait pas tout
reprendre bon ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a compris là quand même
bon pour faire une pause du coup on a
bien compris la position
on comprend des trucs quand même
ça casse pas trois pattes un canard mais
on comprend des trucs
bah là c'est vraiment une partie qui est
partie pour durer
mais je sais pas ce que c'est le Hopper
en fait il y a deux semaines il est pas
sûr c'était moi mais moi je suis pas sûr
que c'était moi non plus
non c'est parti pour durer
[Musique]
ok pour moi c'est logique là
il va faire à 5 enfin ça me ferait
tellement logique vu l'enchaînement des
coups
donc OK
il va préparer
à la casse quoi
j'aimerais bien me mettre 3
quoi qu'il en soit
depuis quelques coups
[Musique]
c'est pas sûr ce sera dur à faire mais
à partir du thermostat j'ai l'impression
un petit matin on sait pas
concentré n'est pas
concentré
on a fait le tour là c'est vrai que on a
plus qu'à attendre de voir ce qu'il va
faire et comment
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de chemin qui
mènent à Rome ici tu veux faire de la
meuf de faire dame de épices c'est ça
change pas forcément grand chose non et
probablement rien en fait
la partie tu veux faire un truc bien tu
vois
le temps mais qu'en fait ça se joue pas
ça
ça peut et du coup tu veux maximiser tes
chances mais nous on sait que non
en fait quand tu es sur la partie tu
sais pas mais quand tu as les évalues et
tout tu vois que
fait un moment donné il va falloir que
digne défende bien
et ça va se jouer à ça va jouer à un
moment donné
question intéressante je sais pas mais
question ils font quoi les secondes
pendant les parties je crois qu'ils
dorment c'est ce que j'aurais conseillé
de faire moi mais je sais pas si non
mais je crois que c'est ce qu'ils font
ils dorment en fait il faut pas regarder
les parties
parce que tu bouffes de l'énergie à
te dire il a pas vu machin
même émotionnelle donc faut pas le faire
mais donc oui tu dors en fait ou tu te
détends ou alors bah toi tu as du boulot
à faire et tu bosses quoi ah mais tu
regardes pas normalement enfin si tu
peux t'empêcher de regarder tu regardes
pas
c'est un conseil de baquis parce quand
j'étais avec l'équipe de France il
m'interdisait de suivre les parties en
direct bon je regardais quand même mais
faut pas regarder enfin déjà ça sert à
rien parce que tu
vas rien faire plus tu influences pas
quoi
donc c'est mieux de dormir et du coup tu
es efficace pour travailler après plus
tard
peu importe mais vaut mieux pas
donc il a fait à 5
il peut pas il peut pas détruire son
avantage en un coup non après si choisir
un mauvais plan il peut les friter en
deux trois coups
mais là je crois qu'il y a pas il y a
pas de mauvais coup pour les blancs
[Musique]
donc ça sert pas complètement à rien et
tu dis à vas-y à toi tu as déjà mis tous
tes pions sur noir bonne chance
qu'est-ce que les Noirs comme utile mais
pas grand chose je crois non mais en
fait ils vont checker checker mais dame
F2 du coup c'est utile je trouve et si
tu veux faire
en fait la vraie mais quand est-ce qu'on
veut faire la F4 est-ce que c'est jamais
est-ce que mais moi j'attendrai
longtemps pour le faire en fait
alors attends il a joué
il a joué un coup
il va pas changer ouais
j'ai l'impression plus on a regardé un
petit peu avec la turbinette plus le
truc de ramener le cavalier F5 me
paraissait fort ben c'est pas qu'on
fasse des trucs mais j'ai l'impression
donc je pense c'est le moment du coup de
prendre en D1 puisque maintenant il y a
plus qu'à les prendre autour des 8 c'est
évident
[Musique]
pour voir
en fait
je fais une faute je voulais faire Dame
des deux
on envoie une tour rien faire en C8 elle
devient assez longtemps du coup les gens
peuvent être faire tour des trois tours
3 tours des trois ou trois tours de
tourner de fin reprendre la colonne des
peut-être faire 5 aussi ça se regarde et
comment ça a travaillé avec des pièces
plus actives et
un peu le droit d'adverse et aussi un
moment ramener le fond un C3 quand il y
a 5 et tapé quoi
donc ça ouais on est content du coup il
parait prendre quatre mais c'est tout le
problème du cavalier F4 c'est que le
cavalier quand on le ramenait en F5 qui
faisait mal mais là en F4 il est pris
dans le
fouet donc en réalité on peut se
re-décaler avec le cavalier des noirs et
finalement le foot vient utile
mais là on a peut-être raté avec les
Blancs justement mais bon
qui est aussi et
là c'est pour montrer un autre cas de
figure quoi cavalier prend faut prendre
tout reprendre à me prendre à me set ça
reste mieux pour les blancs mais là on
doit il reste plus à cette pièce
tu montrais tout à l'heure même si on
gagne C7 mais au prix de l'échange des
dames c'est nul quoi et
l'autre truc c'est que dame fou comme ça
ça m'a pas en fait c'est bizarre tu as
l'impression d'attaquer mais ça ça
m'aide pas en fait je m'étais jamais
trop posé la question je lui en partie
et puis je comprenais pas non tu peux
pas m'arrêter
en machin tu arrives pas ouais donc je
sais enfin tu as l'impression que tu vas
mater mais tu peux jamais avoir vécu
c'est que ce qui m'attend
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que j'ai juste pas envie
d'échanger les tours
donc c'est quand même très logique de
faire ça autour des 8 et là l'ordi dit
quoi
on va essayer de comprendre
mais je crois qu'il y a rien à
comprendre
évidemment il y a les pions doublés
étaient mis avec les blancs mais juste
ça va pas suffire tu vas la jouer avec
les Blancs et il faudra encore jouer
avec les noirs pendant un certain moment
et défendre mais là c'est sûr que tu
t'approches de la nul mais d'ailleurs
peut-être même le droit ça tu peux déjà
faire baisser 5
on va bouffer si tu veux
est-ce que il peut vouloir tourner trois
donc c'est un peu la question l'autre
question qu'on se pose mais ça j'ai un
sens
ouais alors cavalier O2 c'était le plan
qui paraissait bon que tu avais que
guéri avait
mais l'ordi qui te montre le plan de
Nantes garder le cavalier pour aller sur
la cave F5 c'était plus fort donc on a
quelque part vu la réponse à ta question
en fait c'est bien mais c'est pas c'est
bien concrètement tu arrives pas à le
faire bien mais pas assez
bien mais peut mieux faire
ça veut pas dire que ça suffira pas pour
gagner
on va voir de toute façon
mis à part attendre dans ces dans ces
matchs champion du monde on peut pas
faire grand-chose
donc on va une nouvelle fois attendre la
réponse de Ding et voir si joue le
logique tu reprends des 8 après la
difficulté en partie c'est toujours de
comprendre
pour nous c'est facile on a l'évaluation
donc c'est pour ça on voit des coûts
logiques et on sait lequel d'écologie
qui est bon quoi en plus on peut bouger
les pièces et donc après ça bouge les
pièces je pense ça change pas grand
chose alors niveau
non mais ça part de la clarté c'est à
dire que là elles vont battre tous les
calculer de tête mais
c'est marrant parce que le cavalier je
reviens un petit peu du coup pour juste
pas fait tourner en fait
genre là ok admettons en fait
ok mais faisons à trois
B6 5
et qui est bien
peut-être que tu es pas content de
laisser doubler en fait tu es content
c'est ce que tu avais dit au tout début
d'ailleurs tu dois être content
d'échanger une paire de Tours pour
éviter de te faire pénétrer une
et tu fous le cavalier F5 c'était
probablement le plan le plus fort à
vérifier après un faudrait une analyse
plus profonde
donc sûrement c'est pour ça que ici d'un
FF de ton a échangé une et après tu
décales maintenant et hyper dur
pour parler un peu avec lui il pense que
ne pouvait favori
mais j'espère
on verra
on se donnera la réponse le 31 avril le
30 avril plutôt 31 il y en a pas en
avril je sais pas quel jour ça se
termine exactement ce que leur jour de
de fin de cérémonie de clôture
d'aéroport de jours de repos je ouais je
crois que ça finit le 30 si à 14 parties
plus des partages et je crois que sans
le départage c'est le 28 non un jeu de
bien j'ai tout noté tu as tout noté ok
c'est fini 29 la route 14 d'accord le 30
les time right
et c'est le jour de départ aéroport
donc comme d'habitude le jour le jour
annoncé de fin c'est un jour qui ne joue
pas non non c'est ce que je pensais
parce que c'était annoncé la fin là pour
le premier mai donc ça ne pouvait pas se
terminer le 1er mai sachant qu'en plus
il y a une bonne probabilité que ça
aille pas au 14e
mais au moins 13 à mon avis dans ce
match là je le vois pas faire moins de
non ça réfléchit ça réfléchit en salle
de repos probablement pour digne de
nouveau
bon on va voir là c'est Ding qui
réfléchissent à un coup à lourd de
conséquence pour lui mais je pense
tu fais rien genre
tu peux en savoir des petits soucis
parce que c'est le cas de 4 donc on va
se le faire échanger
on va se prendre la dame F4
cette fois ils font pareil
pourquoi pas admettons pour faire des
tours des deux
mais ouais ça qu'est-ce que
on va avec les Noirs évidemment mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire avec les
noms
F4 F5 on fait faux F4 G4
dg3 et je sais pas on hésit dans H4 G5
ou 5 mais je crois qu'on va arriver à
faire un des deux ou les deux d'ailleurs
donc j'ai un son de mécaniquement là on
met une pression
on met une pression
peut-être pas suffisante mais on met une
pression ça c'est sûr
donc du coup c'est pour ça ouais ouais
d'échanger les deux tours
de vouloir échanger de Tours ça nous
fait faire une concession quoi
on les échange et a priori ça va pas
suffire son échange pas mais du coup on
lui laisse la colonne des
ce qui tourne on voit on voit que c'est
la caméra marche il tourne autour et
digne qui continue à jouer depuis la
salle de repos
un joueur qui prend la contrôle de la
table là quand même
Maing
je peux pas le très modeste très fort
mais
en fait il te fait pas peur physiquement
quoi pas trop non non
il arrive non mais c'est bien il a
raison ouais
il arrive bien
il va il arrive donc il va jouer
rapidement à mon avis
il joue vraiment des des chiottes enfin
de là non mais il joue vraiment de la
salle de repos parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il vient il joue vite bon là mon avis
s'attend à se connaître
le coup quand même jouer et il va jouer
un deuxième coup ça pourrait donc il
joue il joue des chiottes
étant donné les coups et donc bon je
dirais de pas échanger pour dépôt mais
il repart
ah c'est ça il joue de la salle de la
salle de repos
c'est bien joué un de la part de Jean
quand il défend bien bah là il fait le
bon truc enfin en fait si il fait ce
qu'on a cru comprendre mais globalement
mais du coup peut-être que
les boîtes pas été assez précis quoi
alors il faut entendre je crois qu'il
peut prendre du coup ce qu'on a dit
alors après bon peut-être qu'il veut
faire dame prend on n'a pas trop
considéré mais mais
soupe on prend ça donnait rien
pour prendre un prank
franchement je dirais A4 quoi
[Musique]
franchement s'il fait je pense de plus
en plus il va tenir
un truc je me disais tout reprendre des
trois dam prend des trois tu as pas de
dames des 8
non mais attends quand même perdu la
colonne mais un cadre B5 je me posais la
question genre de massif B5 et puis
peut-être
bon bah alors
l'idée
c'est genre de truc c'est oui évidemment
ça peut passer mais tu sens que c'est
pas
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
tu vois
il veut il veut échangeant des trois pas
pour prendre du pion et pour reprendre
de la dame pour prendre mais suivant
cavalier bouge
si tu avais le temps de jouer la B3 à 4
donc tu y arriveras jamais mais tu
pourrais jouer les pions passés mais là
tu arriveras pas parce qu'en fait même
cette finale là elle est nulle
et tu bouges plus
donc tu en prends des trois dames prends
des trois peut-être le coup difficile
quand même c'est B5 je suis pas sûr
qu'on doit le faire mais c'est en fait
ce qu'on veut faire avec une heure c'est
la structure les pions sur blanc
la petite chaîne de pion et c'est vrai
que c'est 3 c'est une blague quoi
mais ouais ouais ok
[Musique]
3 est-ce qu'il est une ah mais attends
je suis en train de me dire
du coup
en réalité si tu fais Dame des autres tu
prends à ce moment là tu as la même avec
un temps de plus et tu as fait ton truc
et tu as fait ton truc ouais oui c'est
plus malin de toute façon il peut te
faire ton point de huit maintenant mais
bon tu t'en fous complètement
je pense que je pense c'est ça l'option
tu vas quand même te rapprocher de la
nul là
on va voir ça peut
intéressant en tout cas cette partie
infable une belle entrée en matière la
championnat du monde
une partie sympa agréable à suivre
en tout cas nous on kiffe c'est dimanche
après là dimanche midi devant devant
cette partie de championnat du monde
c'est un plaisir
très heureux on le voit Fab sourire aux
lèvres
non mais au moins
je sais pas j'invente tout le monde peut
être plus ou moins content quoi de cette
partie chez les joueurs genre Ding il
dit ok ça va quand même je trouve des
coups je joue pas trop mal quoi nepo il
avait joué une faire jouer une partie
ouais il se fait passer chez les Blancs
c'est cool
donc tout le monde peut avoir des motifs
de satisfaction pour l'instant
et une époque a aussi être content je
pense psychologiquement de voir Ding qui
part souvent pourquoi j'ai l'impression
que ça peut ça plutôt agréable pour lui
de pas avoir cette pression que Carlson
lui avait mise parce que la dernière
fois si partait aussi souvent c'est
aussi parce qu'il était sous la pression
et oui tout seul mais en tout cas après
je pense que ça pénalise moins digne
comme tu le disais qu'il y a quelqu'un
discret de base donc je pense que lui
laisser la domination de l'échiquier
c'est moins
il est trop rien il faut quoi
après l'ordi donne ton reprend des trois
comme plus fort mais non mais
c'est plus le coup c'est marrant en Ding
s'assied direct n'est pas c'est marrant
les échecs c'est un jeu où les gens
n'aiment pas être assis en face là en
face de l'autre
pas toujours mais à haut niveau le mecs
sont jamais assez en face de l'autre
c'est intéressant
mais c'est pas par éducation qu'ils ont
pas envie ouais c'est la pression
psychologique physique
pour ne pas gêner l'adversaire
mais là c'est pas le cas en fait non non
c'est
juste parce que c'est la tension est
trop forte
donc on est actuellement au 24e coup il
reste une demi-heure à Digne pour jouer
cette coups ça paraît
plus que faisable parce que la position
elle peut vraiment s'aplanir non mais là
il y a pas de
oui c'est pas très très compliqué
il y a pas de calcul de fou les
positions
mais si tu joues admettons bon je vais
jouer des coups vite pour rien
en fait je me posais une question sur
une finale
c'est pas ok est-ce que ça on peut poser
un problème en arrivant c'est 5
j'ai pas envie de faire mais ces quatre
je touche pas en fait
ça se trouve
est-ce que le truc
ultra passif
est-ce que je la tiens ou pas on va
rentrer
qui paraît être la pire mais en fait
même là tu as le droit d'essai donc
c'est que
le aquattro doit suffire
quelle belle partie en tout cas Fab
ah mais c'est sympa enfin il y a une
petite pression ça joue c'est pas sec
il y a un petit peu de sauce
d'ailleurs en championnat du monde
et c'est tout
parce que c'est pas une mauvaise
ouverture la carrocane
c'est pas la salle de repos des joueurs
mais nous dans la salle de repos on a
mortadelle autruche et cocotte et désolé
sympa
des trois à jouer il vient de jouer là
non ouais c'est 5 ouh là
bon leur dit même pas mais l'ordi aime
pas du tout
noir du coup
de couleur opposés ça a pu être la même
non
mais après
ouais mais bon pas le problème c'est que
c'est ça on peut quand même l'attaquer
nombreux en a le fou on a le camion qui
peut attaquer
et si tu fais C6 toute façon tu te fais
ton triangle enfin tu as quand même des
faiblesses donc c'est autre chose mais
tu as fait des sites enfin c'est
une nouvelle faiblesse mais ça résout
pas ça résout pas les problèmes dans le
fond donc
j'aime pas tellement mais bon c'était
pas grave
mais ça m'impressionne moins que
ça fait vraiment l'air de sécher
mais après Dame des deux ouais le truc
c'est que quand tu prends c'est ça c'est
vrai c'est genre tu peux tu peux pas
faire ces six là tu te fais
tu peux peut-être mettre un problème
peut-être que c'est toi qui repart
là-bas ou j'en sais rien moi j'aime pas
cette structure comme ça en fait je
préférais l'autre ou tu donnes peut-être
le pion C7 mais au moins mais c'est tout
et là tu peux vraiment te prendre une
radia de pions
non mais là tu commences à avoir trop de
problèmes tu as le droit potentiellement
faibles on ne voit pas mais on le sait
et
tu as des pions à l'eldame
[Musique]
c'est toujours pareil mais c'est vrai
que enfin
tu aimerais bien faire à 4 c'est 4 B5 C6
mais ça tu y arriveras pas il fait damné
des deux OK
[Musique]
à moins qu'il ait pensait que c'est
prendre des trois étaient l'idée qu'il
est surestimer ça
t'a le temps de faire ses cinq mais dame
prend et puis là en plus c'est cases
blanches là qu'on arrive plus à courir
je sais pas mais c'est
des problèmes il y a pas besoin
mais est-ce que c'est grave on sait pas
non pas trop mais
tu passes pas par la direction la plus
la plus directe
donc tu peux prendre l'autoroute c'était
écrit tu as le panneau tout droit bon
bah c'est bien quoi
le 12 là ça a l'air très bien
je sais pas
ça affaiblit
je peux comprendre après qu'il veuille
vraiment se mettre sur case noir de
partout pour les contrôler mais au final
tu contrôles les bouts de chaîne mais
les baisses des chaînes tu les contrôles
pas quoi
c'est ça donc
le problème c'est la cassé cette hein
clairement mais même si tu avances
l'option ça reste un problème puisque ça
vient de te reprendre par derrière
bah il aurait le pion c'est 5 en D6 on
en parlera très bien
mais là le problème c'est qu'il a une
cible ça serait ta structure de ce qu'on
dit
[Musique]
c'est bon
mais c'est logique en quelque sorte de
parler du début de partie
mais du coup je crois que tu devrais
jouer le Budapest
avec toutes les couleurs
non mais ce qui va gagner il y a
mais il est toujours pas favori pour
gagner mais là il commence à avoir des
chances ouais il recommence à avoir des
chances
mais j'adore ce que propose l'ordi ah
oui c'est beau en fait il veut juste se
barrer avec le roi et à l'école mater
les cases les caches avec ça c'est bien
ça c'est bien c'est
d'accord ça te fait un troisième pièce
pour défendre c'est ça en fait
et tu as plus le problème du roi faible
de l'autre côté donc deux ans après il
faut réussir à avoir le temps non mais
j'aime le concept
je pense que on mettra l'analyse un
point d'interrogation quand même enfin
au moins deux au moins au moins deux
ouais
ce que ça donne trop de cases et ça
donne trop d'options
est-ce que est-ce que Ding a disparu non
mais il joue depuis la salle de repos
donc il ne viendra pas il viendra que
pour jouer les coups
c'est comme ça
on dit des si c'est pas bon du coup s'il
a faiblesse c'est ça
serait bien parce que ça blindrait tout
surtout
attaquer ses sept directement ça devient
facile à défendre là le problème c'est
que tu regardes les pièces qu'il y a en
fait il change bon on change les tours
donc il y a déjà le fou G3 qui attaque
donc ça fait un il y a le cavalier qui
peut arriver en C3 et en D5 ou B5 ça
fera 2 et à la dame qui pourra venir
quelque part en D5 B7 ou quelque part
mais elle va l'attaquer le pion enfin
c'est pas possible c'est un jeu on voit
que c'est faisable donc ça fait trois
pièces qui attaquent un pion et non ils
ont deux pièces par défendre c'est dames
cavalier le fou peut pas intervenir quoi
qu'il en soit il est sur casse blanche
donc et donc c'est un problème parce que
tu te fais attaquer et si t'imagines la
même chose avec le pion en D6 bah là tu
as que deux pièces qui peuvent attaquer
c'est Dame et cavaliers et tu as deux
pièces qui défendent donc tu es beaucoup
plus serein dans ce cas de figure et si
tu mets ton pion en C6 ça crée d'autres
problèmes c'est que ton pion B6 devient
faible et que lui aussi on va pouvoir
l'attaquer trois fois
en fait c'est on fait une expérience
tout le temps vous voyez ce que tu peux
décider un truc comme ça oui mais
c'était mieux l'autre enfin
c'est quand il y a 4 tu as pas envie de
prendre et puis la dame va partir il y a
enfin non non mais ça ça va pas
donc voilà
donc d'un côté ou de l'autre
ça va pas aller
au temps attention il est en danger
ouais ouais puis un moment ça va être
plus compliqué d'aller à la salle de
repos ici quand tu auras plus que 3
minutes
il a vraiment fait c'est 5 c'est une
grosse faute
première fois du championnat du monde
mais il va falloir défendre ça crée un
problème ça crée un réel problème la
femme
va voir on a plus qu'à attendre les
coups
c'est ouais c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile bah écoute il réfléchis
de toute façon inéluctablement bientôt
jouer parce que 23 minutes
c'est ce qui lui reste donc c'est obligé
qu'il joue dans les dans les 25 minutes
à venir là au moins un coup
tiens juste pour répondre à Martin qui
qui dit que c'est un peu dommage du jeu
niveau des coûts ou des joueurs avec
l'ordi bah en fait on est plutôt
d'accord avec toi c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire tout le temps nous hein des
fois tu nous entend dire oui ça c'est
trop ordinateur est-ce que ça doit être
objectivement le meilleur coup d'ici
humainement t'es pas censé le trouver
bon on va pas critiquer c'est 5 là pour
le coup c'est
pas parce que leur dit que c'est bien
c'est mal c'est juste bizarre en fait de
faire des trous dans la position c'est
visuellement humainement moins bien que
darfait l'autre chaîne de pions
pour confirmer automatiquement ça passe
ou ça passe pas parce que ben on est un
peu obligé mais on n'aime pas juste dire
il est nul il l'a pas vu il est fort il
a vu enfin
ok j'ai un ordi il peut dire ce qu'il
veut ça reste des hommes qui jouent et
si tu peux pas trouver parce qu'il y a
une pointe après 14 coups un truc
complètement invisible bon comme le
cahier des 5 de tout à l'heure bonne
chance quoi mais ouais donc c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire
après on se sert de l'ordi un peu voilà
comme dit cave pour vérifier parce que
bah nous justement on est moins fort que
donc ça nous assiste bien de voir qu'on
donne pas des ventes trop débiles
mais là c'est 5 c'est critiquable juste
après ça doit suffire
pour nul mais
c'est pas le plus simple et ça crée de
nouveaux problèmes parce qu'en fait
l'ordi du coup il commence à te faire ça
maintenant ça et H5
H4 mettre le ranger 7 et puis ça devient
ça devient
à droite pour défendre ça va commencer à
être compliqué quoi et puis tu peux te
tromper tu peux commencer à tromper
non non mais je sais pas comme d'hab de
toute façon il faudra voir la fin de la
partie pour faire un grand
commentaire et résumé mais c'est 5
et au delà critique bien qu'il est pas
tout à fait bien après ce coup c'est
qu'il a joué tout reprendre un tour
pendant un tour des 8 tours des trois
c'est 5 c'était son enchaînement et la
dame des deux qui est quand même le coup
le plus logique et réfléchit et il
réfléchit pas cinq minutes hein enfin il
est en train de gaspiller 13 minutes sur
les de la demi-heure qui lui reste donc
il utilise un tiers de son temps
sur la variante main après quatre coups
sur le enfin sur le truc le plus le plus
challengeant donc
Satan a prouver que lui aussi il a un
peu sous-estimé ou surestimé quelque
chose
je trouve c'est une genre de peau parce
qu'il est bon pour l'étude les petits
trucs tactiques de dames double attaque
à la fin un petit machin de après il a
regardé beaucoup le temps reprend des
trois dames prendre des trois à quatre
dames C3
dames C3 donc qui était pénible et il a
pas réussi à remettre dans l'autre ordre
à commencer par parce que nous on a
quand même été ouais je sais pas
non après bon peut-être il va faire un
setup qui va très bien qui va te ramener
le roi la dame et qu'on dira finalement
c'est 5 bizarre mais très fort bravo
Ding
[Musique]
possible
on va voir en tout cas on a le temps Fab
et donc on en a 25e coups de temps et au
40e donc il faut encore jouer qu'un
scout 16 d'ailleurs pour dingue qui a un
demi coup de retard comme il est noir
et il ne lui reste plus que plus que 19
minutes le temps qui qui s'écoule qui
s'effrite
ces graines
c'est bon tu peux faire des frites tous
les graines mais ça me nuise
qui fondent comme peau de chagrin
tu m'as fait mal là-dessus Fab j'avais
le
match un greened ah je suis pas bien
et il fait ces six ah ouais non il est
con il est à côté il est complètement à
côté
bon il veut vraiment il va faire C6 B5 à
4 C4 il va pas mais ça sent vraiment
long et du coup il y avait qui c'est toi
qui a 4 moi j'aimais bien j'aime bien
les aller et
bon tu en prends vite ça semble logique
parce que déjà dame prend pas on échange
des dames et on fait la petite
fourchette c'est ça donc ça on bouge
tout enfin déjà on prend des 6 et puis
je pense qu'il y a au moins un des deux
options qui vont encore sauter après
donc ça déjà éliminado
donc on reprend qui va les prendre
l'éloigne il va plus venir en D4
j'aimais bien qu'il y ait ces trois mois
mais peut-être la meilleure mais
juste pour voir quoi
et 5
il va peut-être finir par y arriver à
faire son truc
j'ai pas
[Musique]
réussi à faire c'est faire un truc pour
bien expliquer il va réussir à faire un
truc comme ça
on peut faire on fait ça
et puis on joue un coup et puis il fait
son truc qui bloque tout et après
défendre il devrait y arriver ça oui
enfin on imagine que oui on imagine que
oui sans les cavaliers c'est sûr avec
les cavaliers ça peut rester un peu
chiant
mais bon
ce qu'on a pas mieux alors
06 ou 0,7
je crois qu'il peut se faire planter un
moment justement un truc
franchement autant en épaules j'ai bien
aimé enfin ouais je trouve que le niveau
de jeu là il est quand même sur la
partie globalement il est pas ouf quoi
il joue les coups normaux mais il a pas
le meilleur plan mais enfin genre c'est
bien enfin ça descend c'est normal enfin
mais c'est pas exceptionnel c'est normal
mais dis là ça me paraît enfin le a5 C5
C6 j'ai une pas vraiment une nouvelle
fois les échecs c'est compliqué enfin
c'est voilà nous on a les ordinateurs
les machins les Evans on se répète mais
c'est toujours la même chose mais là ça
me paraît humainement des erreurs
évitables quoi alors après il est
cohérent finalement enfin si C5 son idée
c'est de faire C6 je commence ce qu'il
fait j'aime pas ça c'est deux choses
différentes mais moi je comprends ce
qu'il fait je comprends ce qu'il fait
mais juste il se trompe complètement
mais position difficile et il fait
contresens mais on a on l'a dit c'est un
Ding c'est un joueur qui a du mal à
rentrer dans les compétitions
dernièrement depuis la période covid
c'est un joueur qui a un mauvais score
globalement contre Yann donc il y a
beaucoup de facteurs un petit peu
négatifs pour pour lui de but en blanc
j'ai envie de dire début de match mais
là ça ne va faire que ça gravé parce
qu'il a le DA F4 est enfin c'est pas du
coup dur hein non la face c'est cool
logique et facile mais ouais il se
retrouve vraiment mal il va se prendre
l'impression la pendule en plus la dépôt
il va commencer à t'enchaîner non mais
je trouve quand même que c'est il y a de
bonnes choses relativement mauvaise
partie pour pour Ding parce que c'est
des erreurs de compréhension je sais pas
c'est pas
je lui souhaite de tenir mais
je sens pas trop quoi ce que je te
propose c'est qu'on fasse la petite
pause maintenant avant le jackpot et le
moment décisif qui va arriver dans dans
la demi-heure à venir bien sûr donc on
fait une petite respiration maintenant
et on est de retour dans un peu moins de
10 minutes à tout de suite les gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Mesdames et Messieurs la pause qui
s'arrête maintenant mais qui s'arrête
qui s'arrête maintenant mais on a on a
on va avoir l'arrivée de d'un invité de
poids j'ai envie de dire Fab qui va nous
parler un peu de la partie
et amener toute ta compréhension il a
pas été super élogieux hein
on préfère vous le dire
mais ça va ça va arriver
et nepo ouais bon il sait pas pendant
qu'on était parlé c'est pas passé grand
chose d'un F4 B5
il est rentré et puis il va faire après
la question c'est oui est-ce que c'est
ça tout fout des 6 enfin les deux
peut-être sont envisageables
quand même je préfère quand tu bouffes
hein
plus à l'aile dame aussi qui part donc
ouais moi je préfère à 5 c'est visuel
pour les raisons explicitées par keV
bah c'est plus c'est pour nous c'est
plus logique en tout cas après
je sais pas ce qu'on dit leur dit mais
oui
bah nous là mais moi je serais plutôt
parti pour pousser cette
donc
bon de toute façon je m'en suis pas
tarder à jouer
il va jouer dans les dans les secondes
il y arrive comment dire
j'y verse pas dans ces dans ces cas là
il clique et puis voilà
moi après il a tellement une belle
position il a 40 minutes 12 coups et il
a quand même deux beaux coups donc il
peut
il peut hésiter quoi
difficile
le savoir lequel des deux jouets et
c'est vrai qu'on a un joli cadrage qui
arrive sur surpo
ah bah voilà yoyo le boss le boss qui
arrive qui va qui va prendre qui va
prendre la chaise et qui va s'installer
une fleur yo ça va ça va les
francophonie la Francophonie qui est là
j'ai des lunettes si tu veux écran pour
faire les Rudy ah tiens je prends un
moelleux
parce que ça fait Rudy quand t'as tes
lunettes dans des sens les lunettes
c'est quand même plus difficile
donc là qui va venir et qui va nous
expliquer un peu la partie ouais je
pense qu'on va être team lunettes
l'arrivée de Vlad là qui va nous mettre
un coup de fouet
je pense qu'on doit tous les deux mettre
les lunettes quand on est on est érudit
et intellectuel non
[Musique]
bon écoutez il est parti bien comment
c'est mais puis
ce que j'ai vu au plus tard c'était pas
du plus haut niveau possible de la part
de deux je pense que une fois n'est pas
obtenu un grand avantage il a joué moi
le moins basse puis dire déconner avec
ces mouvements de pion donc logiquement
ça va se terminer par les victoires de
l'épaume
bah pourquoi bah malheureusement le
problème éternel de dingue il est il est
pas confortable de les positions
possibles il est il est il a des
instinctes autour de ce truc quoi est-ce
que c'est pas genre vraiment d'entrer
très inquiétant pour pour Ding parce que
déjà il a du mal dans les contrepo dans
le matcha n'est pas le domine assez
assez fortement et là il se fait
défoncer première ronde
pour moi parce que je suis au fond pour
et malheureusement c'est le carrément le
pire début du mois je peux passer quoi
moi je dois quand même malgré tout ce
que je dis avant et malgré que je suis
pour dire que je dois dire quand même
grand bravo pour les Russes qui ont
juste trouvé te trouver une nouvelle
direction
[Musique]
ça a toujours existé ça a été toujours
joué pas souvent ou par les joueurs
d'élite moi ici ça jouait tour E1 c'est
presque jamais arrivé si tu veux
d'ailleurs je peux te montrer en truc
marrant de l'ouverture après tout le
monde
parce que je pense dans mes fichiers
après on va repartir du début pour pour
que tout le monde suit donc 4 5 et 5
machin à 6 x 4 F6 petit rock faut 7
coups français 6 ici donc le coup
d'où l'idée de rentrer dans ces
structure contre dingue le truc c'est
que les positions de résultats
commencent à
comment s'appelle
comment devenir comme dans les Antibi
Landes avec tout saucisse mais le
problème c'est Ding c'est pas un joueur
de Burn donc si tu veux c'est le
stratégies alors un petit digne quoi
parce que au compteur centre par exemple
je pense le régime face à quoi
et alors ok ici deux trois le plus
populaire après quoi de prendre les
nuages
et maintenant premier ancien c'est que
les deux
je peux partir
les Noirs jouent toujours gendre Thor 8
et après ça cavalier
qui a été joué plusieurs fois par guérir
d'ailleurs j'ai regardé un peu ce
commentaire aujourd'hui en anglais je
dois dire que parfois elle est excellent
et puis donc
l'idée sur cavalier de cette Decathlon
dans mes fichiers je pense que j'ai eu
ça c'est marrant c'est hyper logique
comme quoi en plus oui en soi moi le
problème c'est que comme les brandes ont
toujours pensé qu'ils veulent faire les
pousser frère ils n'ont pas voulu à
l'heure de écarter le tour donc les
colonnes et si je pense je peux me
tromper parce que malheureusement mon
ordi il fonctionne pas maintenant donc
je peux pas vérifier mais je pense j'ai
eu dans le fichier une ligne c'est
marrant pour le 4
comme la première ligne H3 x 5 G4
je sens que et maintenant en cours
si les gens veulent chercher ouais on va
le dire parce qu'on va suivre le direct
mais foot et 5
mais c'est beau quoi toi tu as su mais
un tel que Jing n'a pas su ouais
je n'ai pas l'ordi et regarde
[Musique]
ridicule imagine finale du championnat
du monde le mois pour la Corée
voilà donc ok oui ok
bien sûr et là ok
[Musique]
sinon dans cette position là sinon
parce que bien sûr dégueulasse par
contre après quand c'est fou d'ailleurs
parce que nous on voulait faire ça ça et
ça avec femme plutôt
on a pensé à ça mais ça du coup on
voulait ton avis là tu es ce que c'est
grave ou pas
horrifié à l'idée de jouer de ses fous
de couleurs opposés enfin ce qui s'est
passé dans la partie on était vraiment
horrifié et ça si c'est pas si grave bon
en tout cas
à cette dégueu quand même il envoie un
coup intéressant
parce que on peut pas prendre le
fourchette et sinon tant de gens
je pense que si il a joué assez
rapidement que le site n'a pas vu je
pense que c'est juste l'idée de pas
traverser l'esprit et en plus il était
content avec où il est arrivé et là par
contre des choses bizarres on commence
parce que ok F3 ça va et puis ça va et
quand H3 ok encore ça va et là je pense
enfin mon premier instant que cette
transférer le cavalier ce 3 par des
trois pour viser ça
moi par exemple j'irai jamais juste
foyer
que je peux boire quelque temps avec un
tel coup ici midi
pour moi cet épisode et
puis il y avait d'autres choses bizarres
bien sûr avec toute la séquence des
coups de pions sur quasiment de Ding
lieren c'était assez particulier
on a déjà on a on a compris nous avec
l'ordinateur qui a valu deux c'était pas
terrible parce que sur ton dernier tu
voulais cavaliers prend pour décaler la
dame et faire cavalier F5 donc nous on
pensait dame F2 ici mais après cavalier
de prise prise à tour D8 tour des trois
nous on a pensé avec Fab puis après A4
et B5 c'était nul assez facile
doit être nul et de toute manière tu
dois les mettre sur ceci pour 5 à 4
d'ailleurs
il était content de mettre tout ce pion
noir sur
les droits mais il est décidé de répéter
ça sur Youtube après leur dit montrer un
plan intéressant c'est pas si ça marche
mais du coup il voulait juste faire ça
leur dit si possible ramener le roi pour
les protéger
mais oui mais parce que c'est tellement
horrible là ce qu'il fait et on en est
là et il y a toujours pas eu de coup
apparemment pour une époque il doit
hésiter ici entre Fouday si c'est fou
c'est 7 j'imagine bon ça veut dire que
le match contre
pour le match contre
beaucoup de choses parce que niveau que
on commande la Can You pendant très
longtemps et le refuge ici se pousse au
sept l'espace de une minute
donc il veut pas faire les mêmes
[Musique]
il sent le moment et le moment sinon en
parlant de ce que je pense du moins je
te content avant de partir d'apprendre
ce montant je suis content de prendre
que
digne qu'a pris en tant que succès
parce que je pense c'est exactement ce
type de ce content il faut je pensais
que Dink comme il est mal contre
n'importe où
il doit jouer Sharpe quoi et pour ça
rapporte et puis il joue il rejoue son
Marshall et là je me suis dit non quoi
moi j'ai espéré qu'il va faire
il va jouer une Sicilienne et jouer
charme dès les premières parties et
d'ailleurs pareil je je
j'inspiré qu'avec les pointes elles vont
viser quatre premiers pour mater quoi
mais ça on va voir demain
bref le problème c'est que si tu joues
au marché
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce que c'est un joueur de catalan
très réputé c'était ton c'était toi donc
il y avait notamment toi qui avait remis
la Catalane au goût du jour à haut
niveau
c'était guilfend à la fin des années 80
sinon les autres joueurs d'élite non
juste oublié cette ouverture là et nous
on était trois de montrer au monde
désolé de me faudrait peut-être
l'ouverture l'éternel quoi parce que tu
sais qu'il y a inventé la Catalane
exactement bien sûr c'était exactement
ah oui oui je vais jouer le pion en D4
et le pion G3 en même temps
une nouvelle conception on va attention
on va enfin
il est de l'ouverture hein
[Musique]
déjà les positions du roi devient très
hyper solide c'est une petite maison et
puis une fois le fou il sert la grande
diagonale il contrôle
et comme dit souvent Baki quand tu as un
fou en G2 tu peux des fois gagner des
pièces parce que c'est loin
mais c'est loin
jusque là tu vois pas jusque là quoi
qui était connu pour ses coûts tactiques
longs et pourquoi elle était connue pour
ce cours parce que oui même il était
grand il était grand c'est Maxence
c'était son truc quoi je suis loin quoi
je me cache
[Musique]
et là d'après le petit ordi d'après le
petit ordi le seul truc qui gagne parce
que nous en fait avec Fab on était
plutôt alors on a pas calculé c'était on
parlait juste de nos avis comme ça à
deux balles mais on était plutôt pour
manger à 5 parce qu'on disait qu'on
aurait le plan après B3 à 4 pour faire
le pion passé éloigné mais bon sans
avoir réfléchi tactiquement et là ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'après vous
décides Dame des 7 leur dit qu'il faut
quand même faire dames et 7 pour dame
prend fou prends et ouais mais ça il va
pas le faire en fait
[Musique]
avec des ressources bah écoutez j'espère
qu'il va il va se sauver que c'est
bizarre d'avoir pris ces 5 plutôt que A5
enfin philosophiquement probablement il
y a un problème de calcul mais si vous
êtes là dans cette position que vous
réfléchissez lequel des deux vous voulez
manger bah vous voulez clairement manger
à 5 parce que ça vous donne
sur l'île du roi et l'autre il arrive à
tout défendre et comme quoi alors
comment tu gagnes ça
je sais pas le plan est juste logique
après les joueurs ils calculent donc
c'est facile à dire derrière son
ordinateur que tel coup est meilleur
mais là vous décides Dame des 7 je sais
pas juste une version qui avait
peut-être après dans cette peut-être
elle n'a pas voulu rentrer dans
cavalier E6 x 5 il est à 5 quoi les
directions
c'est peut-être ça
peut-être
quoi
très probablement des cartes va tomber
aussi dans ce qu'elle est bien sûr ça va
devenir gagnant non c'est pas en fait
pourquoi il a pas joué mais ouais ça
paraît
c'est juste que si poussez cette marcher
c'est beaucoup plus logique d'aller
prendre à 5 que prendre ses cinq oui
donc c'est ça en fait tu t'es peut-être
trompé Vlad c'est à dire là retenu les
leçons de son truc contre match contre
carlsan il joue pas en une ou deux
minutes il prend le temps et bon
pourquoi tu prends le temps en fait et
peut-être il est comme comme le comment
s'appelle l'homme
le bourbon sur qui Napoléon on a dit
il a rien oublié hier il y a rien
compris
[Rires]
on l'a dit on va pas aller essayer de
gagner à 5 maintenant de toute façon et
B7 donc il doit forcément partir pour
vous français 5
moi je dois dire qu'à moi aussi
personnelle moi aussi quand même souvent
merdé de les positions gagnantes tout
simplement parce que trop d'options pour
moi c'était toujours dur de choisir
quand il y a 4 5 et tout paraît beau
j'étais pas bien pour piquer le bon coin
je crois que c'est difficile pour tout
le monde globalement je crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose de dur aux échecs
en train de réaliser un grand avantage
je pense que le plus souvent dans les
chirurgical mais bon c'est un mec quoi
et c'est le plus fort
des nuls par contre je le vois à côté il
est vraiment chirurgical
là il a fait quelque chose de magnifique
en Islande il a pris trois bails
bref c'est quand tu fais nul sans jouer
avant
bien sûr
c'est ça c'est l'heure où tu as pris
l'habitude
juste l'Islande je suis content
que tu jouais ça n'existait pas non ça
jouait que de les appeler en américain
moi je fais dans ma vie qui ont lieu
après américaine d'ailleurs ça me rend
qu'ils sont que je gagne
j'ai gagné 3 dollars
[Rires]
o quoi et finalement
c'était quoi comme open
du monde à l'époque peut-être le
meilleur d'ailleurs
le point de New York quoi ah le fameux
le fameux
hyper fort d'ailleurs il y a plus de
grands open actuellement aux États-Unis
ce que j'ai vu sur les parties tu sais
ce que les gens faisaient dans le groupe
de leader moi aussi j'étais dans
toute évidence ils ont vu attendez les
résultats des autres sur plusieurs
logiciels et puis vers la fin ils ont
quand même arrangé les parties il faut
oui ils ont été là pendant 5h en train
de rayons faire et puis
il y a décidé le meilleur du meilleur
résultat maintenant ils ont plutôt
les derniers
donc je tout fais pour ça vraiment pour
finalement je voulais savoir après le
parti le midi je veux pas ci-dessous
après la partie le midi et pourquoi tu
as fini
pourquoi tu as fait nul c'est trop
adoles tu vois
j'ai raconté il y a pas longtemps en
live une anecdote dont une anecdote avec
toi dont je me suis rappelé j'ai pas si
toi tu t'en rappelles mais une fois je
suis venu te voir à ismaï Lovo pour
l'Open Aeroflot de Moscou qui est très
connu
et j'arrive là-bas c'était peut-être la
rendre 5 ou 6 et donc je te vois je te
rencontre et une des premières phrases
que tu m'as dit c'est ça y est les
armées ont pris le contrôle des chiottes
de tes premières phrases et tu étais
tellement heureux quoi
je me rappelais pas mais elle est belle
non
ça va rendu tellement heureux cette
phrase
donc oui suivant les pays les méthodes
sont différentes
non mais le problème c'est quoi le
problème c'est que très souvent c'est
archi visible archi visible le problème
c'est que les organisateurs veulent pas
sortir les choses sales en public oui
oui bien sûr les organisateurs
comment dire les organisateurs reçoivent
tous les jours 10 lettres que regardez
ce qu'il faut regarder ce qu'ils font et
les organisateurs
[Musique]
il a fait cavalier G3 donc il veut
plutôt jouer pour le match donc
maintenant C4 c'est quand même logique
en soi
encore plus
il va jouer je crois qu'il a joué il a
joué quasiment tempo il a fait cavalier
bon c'est l'autre coup ça protège le
pion
bon à moins les questions comment
enlever au moteur ok tu vois mettre ton
cheval sur après comment tu fais
maintenant c'est une grosse question
parce que pour l'instant j'arrive pas à
voir
congolais fuite c'est contrôler oui que
les filles faut aussi
on va expliquer cavalier F5 c'est 4
disons c'est pour jouer des coups
j'aurais dit
tu vas pas mater là mais après tu peux
jouer cavalier compte fou mais
c'est que bien que pardon
clairement il a été trop excité en fait
ce que c'est comprendre moi de toute
manière ce que on peut témoigner
[Musique]
dans cette phase de la première partie
du mois c'est que les deux ne sont
paraissent pas au top de leur forme mais
bon c'est compréhensible aussi sont
beaucoup préparées le stress de la
compétence
je sais qu'ils ont imité point de métaux
soviétiques mais je sais pas comment se
passe exactement mais dans les équipes
au secours le mec qui joue le match pour
le Coran il se chauffe grave dans toutes
les cadences avant le match il entend
il entend je veux pas dire match rapide
du match de Blitz c'est dimanche
classique tu vois avant donc oui F4 j'ai
prévu quoi j'ai compris en fait
ça je vous mets d'ailleurs pratiquement
parlant peut-être c'est bon c'était très
fort mais en tout cas
ça pose un problème il veut il veut
vraiment valoriser cette majorité et la
bouger quand même ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'ordi en fait il donne
plusieurs coups maintenant juste pour
égalité dans un truc qui très fort ça H5
c'est vraiment fort ça parce que si tu
envoies F5 j'imagine qu'il veut acheter
mais c'est dur de trouver quoique
ok est-ce que tu imagineras mvl trouver
H5 oui oui très possible mais par contre
ta main veut offrir un autre coup bien
que je suppose qu'à moins vous faire
curieux mais est-ce que tu as peur de ça
ou tu pars en C2 et le mec se ramène et
là maintenant il y a vraiment des
réseaux ça moi j'aurais eu peur par
exemple
oui mais
ça ça m'aurait fait ça ça m'aurait
terrifié ce cavalier en C2 qui revient
pas
et si est-ce que j'ai des idées à la
base de données
je peux te taire bon moi aussi je
déplier quoi ouais mais ok je vais venir
là quand même
j'arrive pas à te
ouais non tu vas juste prendre et en
fait
c'est trop en fait c'est complètement de
la merde cette partie là
et c'est vrai que
au parti de l'époque
mais c'est ce que je disais
hier souvent les parties longues comme
ça ont une moins bonne qualité que les
rapides sur Internet ouais
et c'est le plus grand secret de la
maison qui s'appelle les filles c'est le
plus grand maison de cette
organisation comme quoi à chaque fois il
nous vendent le rêve tient Léa vous
allez voir du pur art machin mais le
match de Carson contre par exemple moi
c'était pas de le bon qualité non non
c'était pas terrible justement quoi en
fait je pense les grands matchs
vraiment à toucher les sciences l'air et
tout le reste c'était ça se terminait
avec le match
au niveau de l'égalité va être jamais
dépassé alors il y a aussi eu du Kawana
Carlsen par hasard
moine que les deux autres mais quand
même ça s'approchait oui
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire si les filles
depuis exister que grâce à un seul
événement que le fond quoi
mais tu sais que le jour où ils auront
un bon match de championnat du monde ils
vont t'en parler pendant 40 ans en te
disant oui ce match là qui s'est joué en
2024 était vraiment de très bonne
qualité pour te dire en 2080 tu
travailles dragon c'est 56 ans encore la
confiture ça c'est vraiment de la merde
oui mais tu sais la qualité la plus
haute de jeu avait été atteinte
il s'est dit j'ai toujours su
contre un tel non c'est très très bien
de commencer le match comme ça quand tu
sauves une position comme c'est très
bien parce que c'est horrible
je pense cette ligne avec faux C6 de 7
euros on va plus revoir de la magie non
il va la fermer Ding il va la fermer
cette nuit elle est peut-être déjà
fermée peut-être
mais n'est pas été mal quand même pour
une première partie c'était très mal
comme je t'ai dit c'est pour ça que
cette ligne mais pas avec toi
a été employé contre
les raisons c'est le mec n'est pas
spécialiste de birlande tu veux crier
les structures de Berlin ouais c'est
malin parfois c'est horrible à un moment
donné tu sais moi je joue jamais joué
bien j'étais toujours joueur de
l'espagnol classique et d'ailleurs par
contre j'ai joué genre presque toujours
et avec un ordre de coups très malin il
m'a ramené dans une structure de Berlin
mais très bonne version très bon
vaisseau mais comme j'ai pas d'instant
je parle allemand il t'a déchiré parce
que je traitais ça comme un gosse je
veux même je veux même les honte quoi
oui qu'est-ce que tu veux j'ai laissé la
première fois que je vois ça quoi tu
vois tout ce que maman bouge pas tu vois
pour chaque couple
je sais pas tu vois et tu devais pas
être bien ah ouais finalement je je tout
confondu
et après la partie j'ai dit qu'est-ce
que c'était ma langue de ta part elle
m'a dit bah bah c'est ce que je
cherchais quoi
il t'a pas dit contre un tel que toi
il aurait aussi pu t'envoyer une punch
comme ta compréhension de la berlinoise
me rappelle la compréhension de l'Est
indienne parano
ça y est c'est il s'est réveillé mais ne
pas qu'il va pouvoir s'en mordre les
doigts de cette occasion ratée
toujours là et d'un coup youpi
il joue contre un joueur très actif très
très actif dans ces instants
un peu dans le même style qui me VL
c'est le même le même type de joueur
mais
tous les membres en France
officiers ou pas nous non
[Musique]
parce que je pense je pense c'est très
rare que un joueur de Lead chinois s'est
mis à travailler avec un Européen je
pense que d'habitude soit chez les
femmes soit chez les hommes les équipes
ont été presque toujours entièrement
chinois
donc c'est c'est en
orthodoxe comme une décision il a joué
C4
pour moi c'est très bon de dire en fait
on dit qu'il s'en est sorti mais on
n'est pas complètement sûr hein
oui là ça se voit sur la langue
corporelle de nos pots
il est très très focusé pour utiliser
les manques de temps je pense qu'il va
jouer il pense que il peut pas gagner
cette position normalement déjà il doit
alors
comme comme il faut toujours dans ce
cas-là il est très très focusé sur les
pièges pour cela d'ailleurs
excellent juste c'est le plus grand
piégeur du haut niveau non
il est en mode piège
elle est un monde de chasseur
et ça y est ça repart pour les grimaces
il en fait moi un de grimaces quand même
oui d'ailleurs c'est devenu honnêtement
plus agréable de regarder sur oui
pendant le jour parce que avant avec
tous ces
formations quoi
c'était trop maintenant ça y est il est
comment
il est mieux
et d'ailleurs il a décidé aussi de la
faire un autre bon choix je trouve pour
ce tournoi c'est qu'il a pas fait de
régime
il avait fait un régime avant et
peut-être que ça lui avait coûté et là
il a décidé de garder le bide
bah c'est que plus ou moins normal
d'ailleurs c'est ton corps est là pour
te tel pourquoi tu dois lui
aller à l'encontre
[Musique]
donc là il reste il reste avec avec le
bide moi l'exemple le plus connu quand
le moins qu'a fait le régime ça le
donner le succès de sa vie c'était quand
cramique a fait le régime le seul groupe
c'est l'école avant le match contre
tout changé après il est retourné au
groupe il est retourné à l'alcool et pas
de régime mais il est venu juste
il a gagné il a gagné plus deux il n'a
pas perdu une seule partie et
je me rappelle quelque chose que ça a
été parce que pour nous tous Gary
c'était Mike Tyson
la preuve après le match
une fois le match terminé je pense guéri
a pris la première place donc 14
tournants de l'école il devait pas être
il devait pas être bien et là il fait H4
eh mais du coup Ding il a hyper mal joué
parce qu'il a pas fait H4 lui c'est
trois ça lui interdit qu'à valider 4
je pense que je comprends pourquoi elle
n'a pas fait H4
il a fait un autre coup et se casse très
vite je pense que désolé je pense qu'il
est votre besoin de le toilettes
si si tu penses parce que il est très
très tentant les parties tu passes même
à côté tout semble à quel point les
tendu comme toujours et je pense désolé
de toucher cette question je pense qu'il
y a besoin juste d'aller assez souvent
mais pour pisser ou pour chier
[Rires]
ah ouais bon après si je comprends non
non si c'est logique ce qu'il fait
parce que l'autre a tellement pas voulu
jouer cette finale qui va juste avoir
une version améliorée
bon Ding point joue ce que ok sur le
papier je suis moins bien ouais
c'est ça ok je vois je vais souffrir
mais
rester là quoi
il a pas l'air hyper inquiète attends la
cam on va dire un truc aussi
important pour comprendre la pose H4
donner pour être plus ou moins forcée
pour éviter H4 de la part de noir mais
le problème c'est que ça gravement
affaibli les structures des blancs pour
les femelles ouais maintenant ils
peuvent plus ouvrir F5 G4 comme vous
aviez dit avant mon arrivée il peut plus
ça casse depuis
il est bien sûr tenable même si c'est
pas le spécialité de d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui ce matin là je me suis dit
pourquoi est-ce que Ding est si bon si
le temps de faiblesse
il est pas bien dans les positions
possibles il est pas top dans les dans
les fenêtres et en plus je pense il est
du moins souvent de vendre son droit oui
pourquoi il est si bon alors pourquoi il
était deuxième mondial pendant si
longtemps mais tout moi je pense il y a
une seule réponse c'est que quand il
joue au milieu de sa forme c'est une
perfection
chirurgicale comment elle peut gagner la
partie juste mon tout clean quoi comme
par exemple dans certains dans certaines
catalannes par exemple sa dernière
partie des candidats contre Nakamura
c'est un excellent exemple c'est juste
symphonie parce que sinon comme je dis
je compte peut-être trois grosses
faiblesses les finales les positions
possibles et le papier quoi
j'ai un détail à noter
les joueurs qui jouent
mars
qui qui des fois moins le roi Jean
au niveau de défenseur à moi souvent
donc ils font mal leur Boston et comme
ça et donc ils se sent protégés
bon là ça force quasiment la finale non
parce que Dan B7 dame décises dame F7 à
moins que ça ce soit possible mais
visuellement
une vraie c'est un vrai piège c'est pas
facile de trouver ça et après tu reviens
en G6 et tu vas faire nul mais pas
plus de chance de faire nul mais ça
c'est très népo dan B7
[Musique]
vicieux je me rappelle un moment donné
il y avait la partie double
au niveau du temps
elle n'est pas pendant genre pendant
genre
80 coups a défendu à la vitesse cosmique
métrique pas possible
que tu arrives pas de gagner contre le
mec il les voit trop les journées
tu peux mais il va pas tomber dedans
parce qu'il sait mais il faut 8
cavalier
c'est un avantage
ouais
plutôt agréable pour un ne pas pour le
dépôt dame B7 il comprend bien que dame
décises
on a trouvé trouver des coups de par le
style mais là dans le 17
c'est automatique moi je fais tout de
suite c'est automatique mais il y a
peut-être un autre piège vicieux plus
loin
bon je pense dans cette dame
je pense c'est ça sonne pas rentrer dans
la finale
combien de temps 5 minutes mon 5%
ça devrait passer pour
intéressant comment le match est suivi
en Chine en fait pour moi
parce que vraiment donné katia a joué
son match de distribution rapide
et
ok j'ai pas cru parce que je peux pas
les croire mais les sponsors nous ont
dit que ça a été suivi par 60 millions
quoi c'est possible ça dépend comment il
compte est-ce que 60 millions en direct
60 millions de personnes qui ont entendu
parler du match tu sais des fois
[Musique]
non toi tu penses mais non
non ça dépend comment ça dépend de la
manière de compter les 60 millions
c'est vraiment étonnant
tu peux tu peux arriver à 20000
personnes qui regardent en direct et 60
millions enfin c'est
ça dépend s'ils ont des chiffres
honnêtes ou s'ils font des chiffres
ultra gonflés
ça c'est dur à dire mais si les chiffres
sont honnêtes
à la fin de l'histoire j'ai dit au mec
de l'effet des est-ce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer s'il vous plaît l'info
officielle quoi oui oui bien sûr oui oui
bien sûr
c'est pas très bon signe 60 millions oui
bon
il est revenu en BU donc oui ça peut pas
être très bien joué de te faire tout ça
mais là il y a juste pas de menace non
tu peux tu as le temps de te permettre
d'un petit aquattro au passage
pour aller pour te mettre tout sur blanc
là-bas ah oui c'est vrai qu'il y a 4 ans
un peu plus facile à faire que 8 fois
quand même pas traverser l'esprit quoi
non mais il y a 4 en fait la question
c'est les blancs comment ils améliorent
maintenant
ok souris il va trouver quelque chose
non c'est sûr mais genre la question
un truc génial mais pratique dangereux
oui il va trouver quelque chose en
regardant
ça c'est sûr
mais au-delà de ça là ça te paraît pas
10 giga dangereux tu fais un 4 bon
d'ailleurs c'est la première fois dans
ma vie que je vois
l'un des adversaires dans le mois je
pour le Coran qui porte la chemise les
premières fois carrément les premières
ça a été toujours les chemises blanches
ou bleu ou grise la rouge la première
fois que je vois
ma dernière il est en chemise blanche
plus sobre
ah non John
je pense plutôt blanche
ouais
bien sûr
donc maintenant
il va faire dames direct vu le temps qui
reste il a plus intérêt à faire
enfin à échanger direct pour jouer un ou
deux coups de plus sous pression du
temps la répéter les coupes pour pour
népot ça sert à rien moi je peux dire
que dans cette position là dans cette
position là moi je suis incapable de
gagner qui que ce soit peu importe qui
un peu perdre dans un parc pour faire
une contre ici parce que je retourne
mais surtout avec le H4 H5 introduit je
veux dire que c'est encore le pion H3
que tu peux faire G4 machin à monter
il y a un peu plus de terrain d'ailleurs
il y a une logique que j'ai appris
j'ai appris comment gagner de telle
pause quand tu sais pas comment gagner
c'est de passer le coup à l'exercice
donc
il peut trouver les moyens de perdre
mais c'est quelque chose qui est souvent
employé d'ailleurs
c'est une bonne technique c'est juste
que c'est pas facile à faire c'est pas
facile à faire
non mais là tu as raison ça paraît
vraiment difficile à gagner façon si
fait il peut tu penses qu'il peut
répéter Jordan Besset dame décès dame D8
dame B8 ou en match aucun sens
là c'est vraiment débile de pas tenter
au moins de mettre la pression
il sait qu'à même que malgré que il a
fait des conneries il est quand même
mieux donc il va pas à cœur de nuls
comme ça historiquement donc il voit
quand même faire en gros
négatif ou hormonalvoile faire comme
tout le monde moi par exemple ici je
cours pas les news qui que ce soit je
joue quand même je pense pas que je
gagne je joue ouais par principe oui
mais ok parce que tu peux pas te mêler
autant et en plus dans les matchs c'est
une faute logique chaque petit avantage
minuscule doit être joué au front
jusqu'au bout pour pour presser
psychologiquement déjà pour
comment dire pour vous épuisé c'est
c'est les règles de match et où il me
faut une fois les règles violets ça se
termine presque toujours au moins le
poursuivre
pareil par exemple tu as gagné une
partie
dans la prochaine partie c'est hyper
condo j'ai pas fait une nouvelle rapide
tu as gagné ta première partie il faut
taper le mec tant que
je crois que c'est ce que dans le livre
de carpov je crois
et je crois qu'il parle de ça dans sa
dans le match qu'il a gagné contre à
Nantes de mémoire mais c'est quelque
chose que j'ai lu il y a 25 ans donc bon
je crois qu'il dit que en mettant la
pression dans les positions avec petit
avantage il a fait exploser
90 le 98 le début je pense que c'est
smash va être 98 où il a deux trois
positions il le met dans le Seigneur
party ah tiens regarde là je vais jouer
ça pendant 60 coups et du coup quatre
parties après tu regardes comment je
l'ai battu parce qu'il en avait marre de
défendre genre
non moi ici il y a une forme d'échec qui
ressemble énormément aux box c'est bien
sûr le match à chaque aller parler du
chat boxing
mais oui c'est les matchs évidemment
d'ailleurs on disait quelque chose un
peu plus tôt avec Fab pendant la
retransmission moi je trouve ça étrange
et de du même avis que toute la phase de
qualification soit dans des tournois
pour finir pour savoir qui est le
meilleur dans un match c'est pas très
logique quoi pour savoir qui est le
meilleur dans des matchs il faut des
mecs gagnent des matchs
[Musique]
parce que les gens on était juste
attirés par ces personnages disons moi
je sais qu'est-ce que ça donne je me
rappelle mille fois que kasparo vient
sur la scène ou Carpo vient sur la scène
tu vois les gens dans le sel
ils adorent les adorent ils peuvent pas
même comment dire tourner la tête
tourner la tête parce que comme quoi il
y a les magiques maintenant
on peut pas dire qu'il y a des
un petit peu Carlson quand même
pas autant non pas cette magie là
j'ai pas eu le sentiment qu'il vient
dans la salle et essayer tout le monde
je crois qu'il y a un truc pas mal pour
faire nul majorités
7 avec aussi peu de temps assez vite
j'aurais été trop heureux il fait quel
B7 bon ça fait nul aussi
à fortiori
de sécurité comme pour
la première fois dans ce match
n'est pas
alors attends est-ce que il y a encore
est-ce que je peux juste
ramener mon roi ici et même si tu
pousses les savons c'est juste quand le
7 parce que ça va pas plus loin il y a
un danger
ouais je six et sur Epson tu veux faire
quoi je sais pas je me demandais je
voulais juste savoir si ça c'était
pas de télé
je voudrais trouver les moyens de
posture rien ne bouge plus toi là je
suis bloqué ouais donc ça on peut pas
donc c'est à dire qu'il faut encore
jouer quand même un deux coups précis
bon le coup qui paraît ça sent pas pour
moi
aussi tout simplement
la case de 8 après peut-être par exemple
tu veux que
moi
et si il fait F5 tu prends immédiatement
des trois et là ça peut carrément
devenir dangereux ok mais attention il
reste il reste de quoi à jouer une 15
pour Ding allez c'est les dernières
décisions vraiment difficiles pour le
joueur chinois il va falloir les prendre
à chaque fois que je regarde
j'ai l'impression que c'est le joueur
d'élite avec les parents les plus
timides de tout le temps
tu sais comment qui se porte comme ça
c'est des petits amateurs qui jouent à
les premières ronds de pain quoi ils
sont là contre toi ils sont comme ça
comme quoi je suis tout petit je sais
pas jouer et toi tu es grand et toi
comme c'est le premier ordre
[Musique]
même si au cours de ce dernier année ça
change de jeu parce que même les
premières rondes des Open ils sont déjà
passés c'est complexe
pas si modeste
le dernier coup du design la surement
fou des sept et Roy F7 43 secondes et
après on fera une petite pause black
parce qu'il reste plus d'une heure ou
deux joueurs un vrai dire tempo
à la place de ce condenses ce soir ils
vont le il va les défoncer bah il faut
des 7 maintenant je pense qu'il va être
ce soir oui mais c'est de sa faute
donc Fouday 7 et fin du designate les
deux joueurs on arrive au 40e coup
récupère une heure
donc ils vont avoir le temps de bien
réfléchir mais la position semble assez
facile digne que c'est lever c'est le
moment pour nous là d'aller souffler et
faire une pause aussi et là il y a quoi
il y a 95% de chance de nul 98 bon je
vais dire un 95 98 quelque chose comme
ça donc probablement bien stérile ben
non là c'est devenu c'est devenu assez
facile donc on se retrouve dans un peu
moins de 10 minutes à tout de suite les
amis
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes de
retour avec l'homme que l'on nomme Fab
et bientôt l'homme que l'on nomme Vlad
donc je vais tu sais quoi je vais
changer les noms des hausses donc Vlad
je vais le changer par femme non enfin
où je le laisse là non
toi toi tu es Family
moi je suis Vlad
toi tu crois
parce qu'on est très heureux quand même
et du coup et je vais donner à Vlad le
gros micro je pense qu'il va kiffer il
est beau celui-là
du coup je vais te laisser ma place
comme ça tu vas pouvoir être avec Fab et
je te laisse mon énorme micro mais je
sais pas bouger le truc
donc qui est-ce qui est arrivé depuis
les premières choses qui me viennent à
l'esprit
et quoi bien sûr aussi ce que vous
laissez ici soit donné rien
bien sûr
le problème éternel de grand l'autre
problème éternelle de douane ici
si tu joues F5 comme quoi tu veux
progresser quand même il faut sans que
ça
donc ce que veut dire c'est que
je vois même pas comment peut-être
peut-être un petit quoi il est venu
direct
peut-être c'est rien au moment où on lui
prend toutes ces cases quoi
[Musique]
peut-être pas trop non plus mais c'est
quand même plus de faiblesse
en tout cas digne il a fait ça donc il
nous donne le pion mais il veut
peut-être venir se venger ok sur X5 je
pense que il voit pas au lieu de trop à
directe il va jouer
alors prochain couple
d'ailleurs après coller de toi c'est pas
que les blancs
[Musique]
et en plus bien bien bloquer les cases
blanches quoi
pourquoi donner les cases quatre temps
que on n'est pas forcément encore
désolé vous savez j'ai pas commenté
depuis 9 mois peut-être mais c'est pas
facile avec ces microbes
déjà c'est pas trop trop trop souvent
que je commentais ici
alors
les questions de ce type m'intéressent
quand même
je pense normalement puis
enfin les gens avec qui il a grandi quoi
donc masculin de spécialistes étrangères
comme je pense la dernière fois il a
voulu
donc je sais pas
déjà je suppose que peut-être elle est
moins soutenu par les sponsors cette
fois-ci que la dernière fois
ok différente
et maintenant peut-être donc il peut
donc peut-être arriver au plus vous
faire une télé
moi il a bien fait comme tu avais dit
et du coup Ding peut-être donc rapporte
et après des Chinois non
c'est pas mais ouais probablement
jouer en Chine c'est pas l'histoire de
hier en fait peut-être c'est une
histoire de leur partenariat qui dit
les tours
[Musique]
ils veulent plus ils veulent plus le
joueur d'échec quoi il y a plus de
nouveau les mecs ils arrêtent tous ils
font les études
c'est vrai que
leur mesure contre les pandémies on
était drastique
[Musique]
un gros gros
ça doit être un drôle de trucs
ouais d'accord bien coller
[Musique]
moi je l'ai même déjà pris dans ma
bouche ce micro
[Rires]
je suppose
pour un best of parce que j'ai dit j'ai
un nouveau micro bien dur
est-ce que il existe des micros en forme
de la glace
bah là c'est un peu comme un plombier
non
comme la glace quoi
et si tu tournes
il a vraiment femme tu te tournes comme
ça pour rester toujours dedans pas comme
ça pas comme ça
[Musique]
j'ai une belle voix tout court qui vient
bon mais pour de toute évidence
complètement dégoûtée mais il s'est
promis que quand même il doit encore
alors passer du temps sur l'échiquier
quoi
200 km qui va pas se lever et
à l'époque il aurait accordé déjà à
l'époque d'ailleurs ils ont le droit de
proposer ici
tu en penses quoi de la règle d'ailleurs
en quelque sorte même si je peux pas
dire que ça donnait des
résultats artistiques je peux pas le
dire mais je comprends comment dire télé
l'esprit du temps
et tout mais
[Musique]
je pense pas que les échecs maintenant
sont plus intéressants à regarder que
je le pense pas
de toute manière elles ont trouvé des
milliers de façon de éviter le problème
j'ai pas répéter dans le bilan
ils font pas mais ils pourraient quoi
plus vite
bois dans le rire d'un personnage de One
Piece One Piece
[Musique]
des Titans je sais pas
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal et c'est
tout mais donc je connais rien
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu as vu comment
le site
de Game of Thrones qui s'appelait
rien
ça m'a énormément plu et j'étais très
très
agréablement surpris
par contre c'est pas du tout moins bien
c'est beaucoup plus
psychologique moins fantaisiste c'est
juste que
voilà non je regarderai mais en fait
j'étais tellement énervé et déçu de ce
qu'ils ont fait à la fin de game of
Thrones que je veux juste plus toucher
quoi
dernière saison de
Game of Thrones je pense l'écrivain
OK et donc il a refait encore
[Musique]
ok peut-être je regarderai un petit peu
alors
bon bon
parlant des échecs
parce que quoi de ne pas fourchette
donc ça veut dire que alors
doivent trouver un faut pas prendre de
meilleure marque il a le temps non par
contre tu joues juste bêtement
en plus on défend donc même si il
revient c'est pas grave
il est temps
de cette partie
après quoi je suppose
[Musique]
vous voyez donc moins vous allez final
on ne peut pas tromper ton propre style
en fait des grosses affiches avec la
tête des joueurs c'est Ding là et
en fait les joueurs sont jamais assis
donc en fait on a que le gros nez et
d'ailleurs je sauve pas que sur son nez
il avait commencé
[Musique]
peut-être qu'elles sont
trop discrètes mais quand noir et blanc
ça fait un contraste je sais pas
et du coup ouais tu en penses quoi tu le
renverrai la caméra de les télés dans
les salles de repos parce que moi
assis c'est chiant non toujours la table
vide
les joueurs vont me dire toujours
tu vois avoir beaucoup du mal de
je suis sûr comme ça depuis très
longtemps que il faut donner les
possibilités aujourd'hui
pendant les parties grâce à un truc
électronique de cuire pendant les
parties pour le public
parce que
peut-être
mais par exemple il y a d'autres combats
par exemple
moi par exemple souvent pendant les
parties je me suis autant manuelle moi
par exemple j'aurais été écrivant massif
quoi pour envoyer au public
justement je pense les joueurs de chèque
il ne s'ouvre pas trop au public
souvent je fais j'ai passé 150 fois le
tour de la salle je sais pas quoi faire
tu peux pas voir ce que les gens
n'écrivent eux ils pourront
déjà n'oublions pas la partie la plus
importante c'est bien sûr pas les nuits
des joueurs c'est comment dire c'est
l'intérêt
public c'est bien pour le dimanche parce
que les gens peuvent alors témoigner ce
que les gens pensent contre les parties
ouais et puis on comprend ce qu'il a vu
ce qu'il a pas vu pourquoi il a joué ça
marche pas que pour les joueurs tu
imagines le tournoi des gosses les
parents sont là ils comprennent pas
grand chose mais ils auraient adoré de
lire ce que leur gosse pense pendant les
parties
et je suis très bizarre que personne
fasse parce que je pense que c'est enfin
n'oublions pas
comment on a dit Fisher je pense les
échecs c'est un grand c'est un grand
muet c'est un grand
l'autre phrase
au sujet
il est dit qu'il dommage pour vous que
vous pouvez voir vous pouvez pas voir
comment sont belles me pensait
qu'on voit que le sommet de l'iceberg
quoi et qu'en fait tout ce que tu as
pensé avant
et en plus peut-être ça a été dur de
réaliser ça il y a 15 ans maintenant
avec tous les
qui diffuse sur un écran une public voix
et Internet on a comme des tweets quoi
par exemple assister
[Musique]
c'est pas ça que moi j'ai une
interrogation à ce moment-là c'était le
29e coup
c'est pourquoi pas quoi
je sais pas ce qui n'a pas aimé
je te dis moi version
B4 est trop sensible
parce que
mais même si comment dire bon parce que
là en fait on gagne l'option avec c'est
ça mais si je fais rien et que lui je
laisse venir défendre même ça c'est
impossible on peut pas avoir un espoir
de de créer quand même quelque chose
dans longtemps
bois moi d'après la gueule juridique
il est possible que je me trompe d'après
la gueule pendant les parties
alors peut-être que après on fait là
aussi enfin on essaye partout quoi
ce qu'il a fait lui ici c'est vrai que
en fait il a juste pas gagné de pions et
rien quoi
tout le monde
tout le monde rêve
mais
ouais parce que quand on voit la partie
on se dit quand même dommage de pas
rester l'autre quoi
mais je crois qu'il a revenu à la table
au moins il est pas dans la salle de
repos
[Musique]
elles ont quoi ce truc rond sur lequel
se trouve l'échiquier
[Musique]
je sais pas en fait
le sol salut je suis vraiment désolé de
je viens de dériver ça vous dangereux de
faire un petit récap de la game s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
Marshall par Ding très prévisible puis
les choses intéressantes se sont
commencé avec
parce que c'est pas populaire quoi parce
que
donc ça rend les structure depuis
ressemble à ce qui en arrive
d'avoir dans le
on peut vous montrer si vous connaissez
pas ce que c'est le Berlin c'est ça et
quand il défendent
et maintenant il faut ceci c'est un
grand coup et cette position on arrive
plus ou moins dans les mêmes structures
c'est quoi la différence
dans les parties avec les parties
c'est que les différences avec birlande
le pion noir sur assise pour la scène et
ça joue souvent souvent c'est important
en fait pour du bien pour de moins mais
il y a des différences et puis le fou
mais pas sur ce 5 mais il est sur E7
normalement le Fou est mis au poste sur
7 je pense
que sur ce 5 en fait
ce monde impression
de toute manière ici alors mes pots a
sorti sa grosse prépa pour cette partie
tour on pense que c'est très très rare
parce que d'habitude soit de 3 soit
quand elle est C3 il y a même un coucou
ok je vis où mon petit note pour le coup
d'un de mes fichiers
mais je l'ai presque jamais vu jouer en
fait
dans mes fichiers il y avait une ligne
très belle
foujeu
H3 x 5 G4 G6
et maintenant
bizarrement faut quatre marches
les Noirs perdent les pièces mais un
joueur foot de 5 avec l'idée de GRG
c'est joli c'est la ligne inattendue
quoi
comme je dis les lignes
donc oui il a fait un coup
il a pas fait le courage j'ai défendu
il y a peut-être 4 coups possible
[Musique]
ok bien sûr
et maintenant
parce que c'est une pièce je pense sur
Call restaurant
et si on prend de la tour il prend dans
l'autre sens et on perd du matériel et
du compère un pion oui donc pas qu'à
voler cette
puis il y avait quoi je me rappelle plus
c'est des
et il paraît alors je sais pas moi je
connaissais pas je disais qu'il y a des
parties d'ordinateurs où ils font ça oui
on a parlé mais bon je sens que j'étais
pas au courant et j'aurais jamais pensé
quoi
donc
déjà
la première question sur dame de 8 il
veut reprendre avec le fou moi je pense
pour défendre
[Musique]
ok dames 3 logique pour garder les
tensions et puis bon fidèle son style
dit que je joue très
[Musique]
dynamique
le problème c'est que quand les jouets
ça il est oublié
dans les parties il y a juste parce que
après dans
mais pour jouer H3 il est venu en fait
et les bonnes gagnent ici je suppose en
fait bon pour les gens qui comprennent
pas c'est ça intercepte la défense donc
les blancs de naissent de prendre la
dame si je prends d'abord ça va pas
parce qu'on fait chaque roi et on
reprend après avec le fou et on fait
encore une double attaque
et
s'il fait tout reprendre on reprend quoi
ouais avec le pion et c'est un peu les
mêmes histoires donc oui ça a été une
belle alternative oui il a joué
et vous aviez pas compris pendant vos
commentaires pourquoi l'autre n'a pas
bouffé sur eux donc
[Musique]
je comprends que ça ça fait peur mais
peut-être que si c'est pas si fort alors
mais oui les dettes F6
alors donc digne de jouer n'a pas fait
ça
il a laissé
assez désagréable
ça en fait on n'avait pas pensé nous et
c'est joli oh ici on prend le four les
bois
comme ça avec le roi très affaibli
autrement les bombes menacent
et mettre tout sur la case G7 bon sympa
pas mal franchement
style peut-être le groupe était trop
contente de se dire bon là je suis mieux
je vais petit à petit oui et là alors
l'autre moment important
est arrivé quand ils ont fait plusieurs
coups feignants
de tourner
les tours parce que je pense que c'est
très modeste moi je refais le point avec
Jean je sais pas avec quel ordre de
cours
juste pour montrer ailleurs le plan est
très très personnel très très consommé
il adore
de crier après quoi les bons vivent
ensemble les bonnes violent pousser un
moment donné on sent que tout le monde
le joueur si agressif
d'ailleurs il a quand même réfléchi ici
quand il est décédé de changer le tour
moi je te choqué quoi parce que moi par
exemple jamais choisi ce temps là
et là donc où et voilà non mais je
pensais que peut-être vous voulez
changer une tour mais pas deux et lui en
fait il a
tout laissé échangé
et ici donc il a fallu sûrement à jouer
quelque chose de jeune tour de trois
boutons ou à 4 les pions comme ça
depuis
et ça devrait aller
ici
de devenir un peu de trucs et ces six
aussi parce que ni trop de pions sur les
cases noires et en plus ouvrir les
diaganales et maintenant elle risque
bien perdre toute la compagnie peut-être
[Musique]
et ouais donc là c'est le moment
peut-être je sais pas il a choisi ça et
peut-être c'est 7 oui
le momentum oui là ici il a fallu être
bien précis peut-être pas faut dire
parce que les deux pions sont assez
intéressant mais plutôt terrassant que
quand même notre en plus quand tu
ramènes ton fou sur A5 pour C5 un
bouffant
avec le foot tu contrôles quand même les
cases de dos ni entre pas ça
très très important pour ne pas
permettre au 15 jours à l'adversaire
voilà donc lui bon il est tellement ni
l'autre
oui donc il n'a pas
osé de bouffer sur ce 5 à cause de ses
aides
justement trop de contre-jour donc il a
choisi le tempo etc donc il a décidé
alors de comme quoi en plus l'adversaire
était dans un autre donc ne pourra
décider de viser le monde autour oui
cette défense a été très impressionnant
il a trouvé à H5 ici comme ça il menace
H4 il provoque les bandes de jouer H4 ce
qui affaiblit grave
et puis comme ça il a gagné quand même
plus d'espace et ça y est normalement
l'avantage en gros l'avantage exactement
bon objet et on en est on en est où on
en est alors il y a quelques coups de
jouets on en est là je crois je vais
bien vérifier
donc les trois derniers coups c'est
qu'il a bien fait aussi et il a fait le
dernier piège que tu avais mentionné
tiercé
mais bon ma mission digne a vu et il y a
plus de fourchette
regardez sur l'adversaire
parce que bien sûr le seul de blanc ici
c'est
de trouver les voies lactées comme
j'aime bien appeler du roi verbes
5 tout de suite on va pas dans cette
partie du coup la volatile sera là mais
bon c'est autre chose non le problème
c'est que je pense que quand tu vas
faire roi 3 comment les F3 je suppose
j'étais en train de dire les conneries
j'ai eu hallucination que le noir arrive
avec le roi sur 200
et maintenant on a le temps non
alors après je sais pas s'il peut
préparer faire j'ai trop avant
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est ça les résumé de ce qui
est en avion aujourd'hui
et voilà la partie
[Musique]
à gauche bon ça y est bientôt on va
retrouver notre fonds
[Rires]
les deux regardent sur la pause
qu'est-ce qu'il doit
[Rires]
est très très stressé en général
il est très très stressé en général je
me rappelle le campus 2016
à fond
est-ce que là je sais pas dans quel état
il a du coup si si stressé pour un match
c'est un peu exhibition non contre Sacha
enfin il y avait de l'argent j'imagine
mais c'était pas et pourtant c'était son
comportement et maintenant ça doit être
bien sûr 100 fois
d'ailleurs parlantine
il est de la ville de bonne journée
[Musique]
le choix est énorme le choix est énorme
bon
peut-être ça va aussi je sais pas ok
alors 1 2 3 4
alors qu'est-ce que il veut
[Musique]
il voit sûrement un truc concret
tiens peut-être il veut faire
l'idée
et ça va faire trois pions de filets qui
vont
[Musique]
donc elle est partie
pas de le meilleur qualité de l'épargner
de l'autre très tendue
[Musique]
je pense et alors une question de
horlice qui avait non c'est pas une
bonne idée que tu as mais c'est déjà
d'expliquer
pourquoi prendre ces mauvais
bah parce que c'est une grosse
concession parce que par exemple
le plus beau de l'histoire des échecs
donc peut-être je suppose les Noirs
tiennent ici de toute manière je pense
justement cette 3D pourquoi donner un
petit quelque chose
tant que autrement c'est juste que
lui il arrive vous voyez moi mon ami
c'est que quand vous avez les structures
telles comme les bandes ont ici cinq
pions sur les cases noires le four
bucate théoriquement elle est pas bon il
est pas top il est vrai qu'il est pas
trop passif il se trouve pas sur 2 ou
sur un an je sais pas moi éventuellement
il est il est pas top donc vous ne
changez pas votre
du coup il a envie de monter comme ça
sur F5 il peut continuer il a plus le
pion en prise
mais ouais a priori ça va être l'heure
de faire F5 et de bloquer les passages
je dois dire que il change quand même au
niveau de ses approches au niveau de son
style n'est pas quand même change il
fait des efforts
j'aurais pu l'imaginer en train de
essayer de squeezer
quelque chose de cette position là je ne
serai partie déjà il y a une heure
où il aurait blessé
quand même il y a une petite
[Musique]
idée pourquoi ne pas faire ça maintenant
pourquoi il le faut maintenant c'est
peut-être parce que il est venu au moins
conclusion que moi peut-être il pense
aussi que Ding n'est pas top de
l'éphémère et peut-être allure
que n'importe quelle femelle
[Musique]
peut-être c'est bien ça comme quoi les
finales et bien sûr complètement nul moi
contre toi
[Rires]
ça part plutôt sur une finaire
Jérémy tout mon argent
je pense
et
en fait il veut te fermer le passage
même avec le roi là peut-être avec le
cavalier et le fou
mais je sais pas c'est bizarre quand
même
pas échanger
[Musique]
bon
oui parce que ça j'ai même si les blancs
gagnent ce pion mais bon ce serait déjà
beau mais ça sent lui
donc ok c'est un
ça y est après comment
je pense
donc
mon pronostic il nous reste beaucoup
et soit il permet de prendre sur deux
cadres
dans ce cas-là au milieu de permettre
l'échange on croit ou trois je pars
à moitié
il nous a laissé le studio
donc je sais pas wedding mais
normalement on a plus pour longtemps
normalement avant 16h ça sera fini
il est de retour
ça y est ça y est il est proposé
ok voilà alors les amis donc elle a été
la partie
savoir en fait les premières parties
dans les matchs pour la couronne on
était souvent moins intéressant que la
suite
de quoi vous féliciter alors on espère
que nos commentaires vous ont plu ouais
on va vous faire un résumé pour
sur la chaîne Youtube et puis on se
retrouve demain donc c'est à 11h on est
parti
on prendra l'antenne un petit peu avant
je crois 10h45 et voilà donc le rythme
en général ça sera deux parties une joie
de repos de partie une journée de repos
il y a juste un moment où au moment à
mi-match il y aura un peu plus
il y aura deux jours de repos sur 3 mais
voilà donc ça reprend et puis bah du
coup on vous dit on vous dit à demain
ciao ciao